Caption: wow that was very quiet well done
Caption: everyone
Caption: good morning sorry guys we're all full
Caption: and we can't have any standing at the
Caption: back sorry
Caption: we need a sign on the door
Caption: yeah
Caption: damian draws a crowd
Caption: thank you for joining us this morning
Caption: i'm very excited for the first talk of
Caption: the day after the keynote
Caption: um
Caption: so we have damien here he is a
Caption: consultant cto architect and trainer
Caption: from brisbane and he's here today
Caption: to tell us the most important thing you
Caption: need to know about microservices
Caption: so
Caption: take it away thanks sir thank you
Caption: yeah there we go
Caption: thank you so much april um this is
Caption: amazing how good are conferences
Caption: um
Caption: this is cool thank you all for coming um
Caption: so my name is damian um as april said
Caption: i'm i'm
Caption: from brisbane um damian am on twitter um
Caption: and i'm here to talk about the most
Caption: important thing you need to know about
Caption: microservices which is somewhat
Caption: clickbaity but i will get there
Caption: um
Caption: for those who can't see well um this
Caption: photo i took on thursday we're sitting
Caption: at the docks on freo um watching
Caption: container ships come in and i thought
Caption: that's a perfect
Caption: perfect picture for this talk so i added
Caption: that one in
Caption: um firstly um i'd like to thank all of
Caption: the sponsors of this event um obviously
Caption: without sponsors events um can't go
Caption: ahead
Caption: and also all of the um the crew and
Caption: volunteers
Caption: for this conference it's been as a
Caption: speaker it's been amazing so far and i
Caption: hope you're all having a really cool day
Caption: cool start my timer all right so who am
Caption: i um
Caption: i'm a consultant cto essentially i've
Caption: been a consultant for a long time and
Caption: i've been a cto of a few different
Caption: companies so
Caption: um a few of these you might have heard
Caption: of ratify which is now telstra purple i
Caption: worked there for a long time
Caption: was an early
Caption: early person at octopus deploy i've done
Caption: a couple of very bad hardware and
Caption: software startups
Caption: that i don't talk about too much at
Caption: parties um and
Caption: and as a result of that i'm now a
Caption: freelance kind of consultancy if you
Caption: know what i call it so essentially i i
Caption: help i found a little happy spot where i
Caption: i work with smaller businesses
Caption: um and bring you know my
Caption: you can see from here and the photo i am
Caption: a middle-aged white guy in tech
Caption: um
Caption: i've got 23 years experience of seeing
Caption: the good and the bad and and i sort of
Caption: work with smaller companies to help them
Caption: avoid those sorts of problems um
Caption: and
Caption: yeah that's what i do and also i'm going
Caption: to talk about this a little bit at the
Caption: end um i'm a trainer at a company called
Caption: stack mechanics which i'll talk a little
Caption: bit about later on essentially to help
Caption: people you know in larger groups to
Caption: avoid some of these mistakes
Caption: uh rambling this is the first time back
Caption: for a while
Caption: all right so the agenda today um
Caption: i'm gonna give you a little bit of
Caption: background and historical context
Caption: um
Caption: about uh microservices i'm a big
Caption: believer that in understanding the
Caption: history of something you kind of
Caption: understand
Caption: what problem it's solving and you know
Caption: why we might want to do that
Caption: um i'm going to talk about some of the
Caption: mistakes that i see um and the impact of
Caption: those mistakes that i've seen and then
Caption: some of the principles and techniques
Caption: and and thinking
Caption: and design principles to
Caption: not make those mistakes
Caption: and i'm going to get into some of the
Caption: sort of tech stack details but um
Caption: essentially it's more around conceptual
Caption: stuff
Caption: so
Caption: some background
Caption: for a lot of years with with ratify
Caption: and also my solo consulting stuff we'd
Caption: often kind of go into the burning
Caption: building
Caption: rescue stuff
Caption: um and often in those situations um you
Caption: get to a point where people are like
Caption: well we need guarantees that this is
Caption: going to work and you know we can't
Caption: guarantee anything because everything's
Caption: on fire
Caption: so what we started to do you know and
Caption: and you know these sorts of approaches
Caption: over the last 10 12 13 years
Caption: is you can't make big promises so what
Caption: we would do is ship something really
Caption: small really quickly and then ship
Caption: something else really small really
Caption: quickly to kind of get some runs on the
Caption: board and and prove things
Caption: um
Caption: and you know these patterns that we sort
Caption: of took out of that um
Caption: eventually became you know called micro
Caption: services
Caption: and lots of tooling and sort of
Caption: infrastructure
Caption: like octopus deploy and and serialog and
Caption: some of the sort of tools that as.net
Caption: developers have seen most people
Caption: here.net
Caption: developers
Caption: about half okay cool um source came out
Caption: of that space where we're just like
Caption: getting in as a consultancy and having
Caption: to solve problems really really quickly
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: that's part of the background of wire
Caption: like micro services the other part of
Caption: this talk is
Caption: we are in a very hype driven industry
Caption: you would probably know this yes
Caption: and it's very cyclic as well and sort of
Caption: part of my
Caption: advantage of being you know in tech for
Caption: 20 something years is you start to see
Caption: the same bad ideas recycle with new
Caption: names and i see a couple of nodes here
Caption: go yes um
Caption: and
Caption: you know sometimes
Caption: those ideas get renamed it was like this
Caption: is a great new thing and i kind of you
Caption: know put on my grumpy old man pants i'm
Caption: like no we've done that you know
Caption: and
Caption: and what happens is
Caption: everyone's kind of jumps on these
Caption: bandwagons and they write blog posts
Caption: because everyone wants to kind of get
Caption: noticed for stuff
Caption: and you've got blog posts like oh this
Caption: is an amazing thing and people want to
Caption: get on hacker news and companies wanted
Caption: to attract talent you know we'll do
Caption: posts um about how they how they did
Caption: things
Caption: um my favorite is uber engineering's
Caption: blog because every couple of years they
Caption: change everything and write a blog post
Caption: about it um you know one year was like
Caption: we've moved away from postgres to my
Caption: sequel because it's faster and then two
Caption: years later they've just finished that
Caption: migration go well no that was a bad idea
Caption: we're going back again
Caption: um and and that's kind of fine for uber
Caption: because they're massive and they've got
Caption: you know billions of dollars of venture
Caption: capital funding and
Caption: most of us aren't uber we don't we can't
Caption: afford to make those mistakes and you
Caption: know rebuild our database
Caption: every you know two years
Caption: so yeah part of the problem is
Caption: very hype driven everyone wants to be
Caption: kind of in on the latest thing
Caption: and we end up with this
Caption: so
Caption: for anyone who can't see this well this
Caption: is a sort of well-known meme um of a dog
Caption: sitting drinking a coffee with flames
Caption: all around him i'm saying this is fine
Caption: and i'm going to repeat this a few times
Caption: so if you sort of can't see the slides
Caption: and you hear me say this is fine just
Caption: picture the dog in the burning building
Caption: thinking that everything's all good
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah we built these things and it
Caption: ends up just in in a disaster and as
Caption: much as i love i actually quite enjoy as
Caption: a consultant you know going to the
Caption: burning building and picking stuff up i
Caption: it's a sick satisfaction i get from it
Caption: it would be great for the entire
Caption: industry if we didn't do it we didn't
Caption: set stuff on fire in the first place
Caption: so my goal today is sort of understand
Caption: why we might do micro services um
Caption: and and some of the thinking we need to
Caption: do so that we can stop um setting things
Caption: on fire
Caption: all alright
Caption: so history
Caption: again this is one of these
Caption: everything old is new again um
Caption: every idea in software is built on
Caption: something before it solving a problem
Caption: before it so i want to sort of talk a
Caption: little bit about
Caption: my version of the history of
Caption: microservices
Caption: and
Caption: so
Caption: again there's some assumptions and
Caption: opinions here but i have you know cross
Caption: check this with a few people
Caption: so it started with something called
Caption: sewer service oriented architecture
Caption: if you knowing nods
Caption: who's who was around when soul was a
Caption: thing
Caption: yeah a good number good number
Caption: um
Caption: so so it was a cool idea and the idea
Caption: was that and this is sort of in the
Caption: early 2000s um in the sort of.net space
Caption: it was like net1
Caption: soap was the great new thing and web
Caption: services
Caption: a few people go oh i remember
Caption: and the idea was good it was you had
Caption: loosely coupled services
Caption: that that autonomously managed a
Caption: business process
Caption: and you could then build applications
Caption: based on those services so you know you
Caption: might have service a and service b and
Caption: server c and service d and then
Caption: application a goes well i would like
Caption: that thing and that thing and that thing
Caption: and the applications that sit on top of
Caption: the services and big companies could
Caption: build that services and everything would
Caption: be great
Caption: it wasn't
Caption: because what we'd end up with
Caption: is
Caption: something that looked a little bit more
Caption: like this
Caption: where every service or every application
Caption: talks to every service and every service
Caption: talks to every other service and they
Caption: were usually all sitting on top of a
Caption: shared database
Caption: and it was just a mess
Caption: and a lot of this was because we got the
Caption: modeling wrong you know it was meant to
Caption: be
Caption: an autonomous business process managed
Caption: by a service but typically it wasn't um
Caption: the modelling got wrong and
Caption: it wasn't self-contained at all it
Caption: wasn't autonomous and everything you
Caption: know
Caption: looked like this and from the last i
Caption: know a few a few of you have worked on
Caption: this sort of fun um you know i worked on
Caption: one where you had a data manager service
Caption: where they'd sort of re-implemented a
Caption: relational database on top of a
Caption: relational database over soap
Caption: and it looked a lot like this and every
Caption: service needed to start in the right
Caption: order or the application would not work
Caption: so then we had a
Caption: service manager run a service or
Caption: something that made sure that things got
Caption: started
Caption: in the right way
Caption: and it was bad
Caption: so
Caption: the software industry came up with a
Caption: great solution to this does anyone
Caption: remember what that was
Caption: it was the enterprise service bus
Caption: um
Caption: which was you know vendors came in we'll
Caption: solve these problems um and an
Caption: enterprise service buses for if i don't
Caption: remember they were they were expensive
Caption: um
Caption: they were generally sold on golf courses
Caption: um to cios and then just put in place
Caption: this is very triggering for you i can
Caption: tell you
Caption: so and again the idea of an enterprise
Caption: service bus wasn't a bad one so the idea
Caption: is that we had our services
Caption: and
Caption: rather than them all talking to each
Caption: other
Caption: they would talk to this enterprise
Caption: service bus and the applications would
Caption: talk to the enterprise service bus
Caption: and the enterprise service bus would
Caption: figure out where to route requests and
Caption: how to translate them and whatever else
Caption: and all of this
Caption: um
Caption: logic was in the hands of business
Caption: analysts and enterprise architects and
Caption: the idea is that the the developers
Caption: could just cut code on these services
Caption: the problem was
Caption: we ended up with so much logic in this
Caption: service bus
Caption: that became very fragile because
Caption: essentially you're doing software
Caption: development in a browser window
Caption: for biztalk was a browser window that
Caption: looked a lot like sharepoint
Caption: writing code in there without
Caption: validation without testing things
Caption: and so what happened was it became very
Caption: fragile so nobody wanted to touch the
Caption: logic in the enterprise service bus
Caption: so
Caption: as
Caption: agile developers what did we do
Caption: we ratted around it
Caption: this is fine
Caption: so
Caption: what came next and this is my again this
Caption: is my
Caption: memory of history and everyone's memory
Caption: of history is a little bit
Caption: you know
Caption: along came um
Caption: rest so essentially
Caption: um there was a guy named jim webber who
Caption: worked at a company called thoughtworks
Caption: i'm sure everyone if everyone here has
Caption: heard of thoughtworks yep so again i'm
Caption: jim weber
Caption: the story goes he was working on some
Caption: horrible rescue project
Caption: sitting in a data center
Caption: trying to fix biz talk at one in the
Caption: morning and just where enough of this is
Caption: terrible so he and a couple of
Caption: colleagues started to just go we're not
Caption: going to put something in this talk
Caption: we're just going to build a service over
Caption: here in tomcat and just put an http api
Caption: on it and and we can call that and just
Caption: kind of you know
Caption: um
Caption: separate some of those functionality up
Caption: and end up writing a book on rest called
Caption: rest in practice i think really good
Caption: book on rest and sort of it was around
Caption: the time that rest sort of became
Caption: popular and and you know thoughtworks
Caption: started to do a lot of stuff around
Caption: these sort of http based services that
Caption: were simple
Caption: built on i think jetty um and and using
Caption: rest and hypertext
Caption: um around the time i first heard the
Caption: term microservices it was sort of it's
Caption: sort of emanating
Caption: from a company called soundcloud i'm
Caption: sure a lot of you heard of soundcloud
Caption: they did audio streaming and downloading
Caption: stuff
Caption: so
Caption: um soundcloud had an application it was
Caption: um it was getting big they were getting
Caption: popular um
Caption: and it was very monolithic very hard to
Caption: maintain wasn't scaling well so they
Caption: hired a bunch of people actually from
Caption: thoughtworks in berlin
Caption: and one of the leaders there was a guy
Caption: named phil calcado
Caption: and so what they what phil started to do
Caption: with his team was was break stuff off so
Caption: had this this big monolithic rails out
Caption: and they'd break some stuff off build a
Caption: simple http service over it and um you
Caption: know and a few other people in that
Caption: space were doing similar things and
Caption: eventually they became sort of known as
Caption: microservices
Caption: so
Caption: the historical sort of
Caption: timeline here is you can kind of go from
Caption: sewer
Caption: to bad sewer to http to rest to
Caption: microservices
Caption: um and then a guy named sam newman who
Caption: was also at thoughtworks wrote a book on
Caption: it which i'm sure a lot of people have
Caption: seen and it kind of just exploded from
Caption: there
Caption: but of course we ended up back here
Caption: where we had lots of services a couple
Caption: of applications but all the services
Caption: talking to each other a lot of people
Caption: did it again with a shared database
Caption: and got the modeling completely wrong
Caption: and we ended up back here this is fine
Caption: so who's worked on one of these
Caption: in my in microservice land yeah a few
Caption: people right
Caption: so
Caption: that's the history so
Caption: where does it go wrong and this is you
Caption: know i've spent a lot of time
Caption: digging out of this and thinking about
Caption: it
Caption: and
Caption: the first place that goes wrong
Caption: is people get way too caught up in the
Caption: tech
Caption: yeah and this is a
Caption: fairly common pattern in our industry
Caption: you've got a problem to solve
Caption: you start a project everyone's excited
Caption: you still don't really know what the
Caption: business requirements are because that's
Caption: someone else's job as a developer um
Caption: and so we're like we're sitting here we
Caption: don't know what to do i know we'll build
Caption: our own framework and we'll build our
Caption: own orm and we'll build our whatever and
Caption: so
Caption: in in in more recent years people then
Caption: get really hung up on the infrastructure
Caption: it's like right we need to build a thing
Caption: it's like cool first we need to do is
Caption: get kubernetes and put kafka and
Caption: postgres in kubernetes and just get way
Caption: hung up on the infrastructure before
Caption: shipping a line of code
Caption: and essentially you start solving
Caption: problems that you don't have yet you
Caption: don't know you're going to have yet
Caption: you know tools are great all of those
Caption: tools that i mentioned are fantastic
Caption: tools and fantastic infrastructure but
Caption: um if you
Caption: start layering on stuff before you've
Caption: even
Caption: understand the problem
Caption: you probably need to stop
Caption: and this is kind of agile one-on-one
Caption: right like we don't do big design up
Caption: front a lot of people do it like a map i
Caption: saw one recently there's some tool
Caption: it's like a graph like a graphing tool
Caption: for sort of object graphs and like a
Caption: team that had not actually shipped
Caption: the system
Caption: and the object graph of services was
Caption: like i couldn't fit it on my monitor and
Caption: they'd never actually shipped anything
Caption: they got way hung up on stuff and just
Caption: solving problems that you know they
Caption: didn't have yet
Caption: so sometimes when i'm feeling snarky
Caption: i'll say to people if you haven't
Caption: shipped one thing
Caption: what makes you think you can ship 20
Caption: tomorrow
Caption: and that makes me popular
Caption: you know i've had this conversation like
Caption: right we need to start this thing it's
Caption: like first thing we need to do is choose
Caption: a container orchestration platform it's
Caption: like well you really don't you actually
Caption: have a bunch of stuff over here
Caption: your legacy system it's a bunch of
Caption: servers and you know it's a proof of
Caption: concept like let's see if we can ship a
Caption: small thing
Caption: and um you know so people just way hung
Caption: up on that
Caption: so
Caption: one of the the
Caption: attributes i've seen of microservices
Caption: architecture that have been very
Caption: successful
Caption: is they've evolved from something that
Caption: worked
Caption: okay like soundcloud example they had a
Caption: rails app
Caption: had traffic
Caption: they might have even been making money
Caption: crazy um
Caption: and
Caption: you know they started with something and
Caption: it was creaky and they sort of broke a
Caption: little bit and started with something
Caption: that worked
Caption: and typically those things
Caption: work quite well here's a problem let's
Caption: take a chunk of it off the ones that
Caption: start with a blank slate and go cool
Caption: we're going to need 30 services
Caption: typically never ship
Caption: again because if people have not worked
Caption: with this stuff before they don't
Caption: actually know what challenges they're
Caption: going to hit so yeah often good
Caption: architecture will evolve from good
Caption: working software or maybe it's not
Caption: working well but you've got something
Caption: that works you understand it and you
Caption: evolve from there so often the yeah most
Caption: of the successful stories i've seen have
Caption: started from something that was already
Caption: there
Caption: and particularly with legacy systems
Caption: i've seen a lot of
Caption: who's worked on a failed legacy system
Caption: replacement
Caption: yeah right and
Caption: generally they're like here's this thing
Caption: it's old it's clunky we don't like it
Caption: it's buggy it's hard to maintain you're
Caption: like cool what we're going to do is
Caption: we're going to start again over here and
Caption: this time we're going to do it right
Caption: and you never get there right like you
Caption: never you never ship it so
Caption: whenever a new requirement comes in and
Caption: new requirements always come in they're
Caption: like well that's not ready and doesn't
Caption: do x y and z so we'll put it over here
Caption: and all of a sudden you're chasing a
Caption: target you'll never actually hit yes
Caption: familiar
Caption: yeah um
Caption: legacy system replacements that work
Caption: really well is you've got an
Caption: architecture that lets you sort of move
Caption: something across at a time and make them
Caption: talk you know we've got this new
Caption: requirement we'll put it over here and
Caption: we'll integrate it
Caption: because software is never done
Caption: you know software is done like a lawn is
Caption: mode you can mow the line
Caption: you know the next day you're going to
Caption: need to mow it again or the next week so
Caption: the idea that we're going to just
Caption: replace a system turn it on turn the old
Caption: one off and we're done yeah it's just
Caption: not not a realistic one
Caption: so now i get to the click bait
Caption: other than all of that stuff
Caption: the one thing that you need to know for
Caption: successful microservices architecture
Caption: is software modelling
Caption: which you know gets thrown away um
Caption: modeling is hard like software modelling
Caption: is hard this is why we have jobs because
Caption: modeling good software is a tricky thing
Caption: to do and it's hard to do in one
Caption: solution you know if you like file a new
Caption: project in your id of choice
Caption: and you go right we need to solve this
Caption: problem
Caption: um
Caption: it's hard right like coming up with the
Caption: design and the modeling is a tricky
Caption: thing to do and it's hard in one project
Caption: if you start with 20 and you need to
Caption: refactor something
Caption: you know all of a sudden you've just you
Caption: know multiplied this problem
Caption: and so
Caption: what people typically do is
Caption: spin out all their services
Caption: 20 of them um
Caption: and then realize that they've not got
Caption: the modeling right and then you sort of
Caption: start routing around everything and
Caption: everything talks to everything else and
Caption: you know we're we're back to that kind
Caption: of
Caption: bad sower thing um and then people bring
Caption: in more infrastructure to solve our
Caption: services are talking too much let's
Caption: bring in a service mesh or poly or
Caption: something like that
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah modelling
Caption: so a couple of common really like common
Caption: sort of code smells or architecture
Caption: smells that i see
Caption: my favorite one is when you've got a
Caption: service for an infrastructure function
Caption: who has worked on a data service or data
Caption: manager no good
Caption: so you know if you've got a service that
Caption: are based around sort of infrastructure
Caption: things you're probably going to be
Caption: having a bit of a bad time
Caption: um but the other main one that goes
Caption: wrong is what gets called the entity
Caption: service anti-pattern or a service per
Caption: aggregate
Caption: did those names just go over everyone's
Caption: head or around me
Caption: who's read this book
Caption: who's actually read it
Caption: who got to the end
Caption: it is it's a it's an amazing book it's
Caption: one of the driest books you'll ever read
Caption: um
Caption: and and one of the things about this
Caption: book is actually who does domain driven
Caption: design
Caption: a few people you're hesitant you're
Caption: lucky i'm gonna get called out in a sec
Caption: so
Caption: you've got some repositories
Caption: some services
Caption: yeah
Caption: do you have an on-site business expert
Caption: that you talk to and develop a custom
Caption: vocaloid vocab yeah cool excellent um
Caption: you're the first one
Caption: so domain driven design is actually a
Caption: book around software modeling but nobody
Caption: gets to that bit because it's a chapter
Caption: 15.
Caption: people get through the first few
Caption: chapters around services and repository
Caption: pattern and blah blah blah blah
Caption: and naming your functions really long
Caption: things and then never get to the final
Caption: chapters
Caption: and eric evans actually i saw him give a
Caption: talk about
Caption: um about this book and he went if i had
Caption: my time again i would just like change
Caption: the order of the chapters because nobody
Caption: actually gets to the to the meaty bit
Caption: so
Caption: you know if you're modeling software
Caption: you might have a customer an order and a
Caption: shopping cart and catalog pricing things
Caption: like that when you're doing your
Caption: modeling and
Caption: that's called an entity or an aggregate
Caption: route in in domain driven design right
Caption: so often what we see is services that
Caption: look like this and you can go and look
Caption: like microsoft best practice
Caption: microservices you get something that
Caption: looks a lot like this and all of a
Caption: sudden we've got a service for every
Caption: entity in our in our model yeah
Caption: does anyone remember javale loewy
Caption: early nope cool
Caption: early so uh
Caption: said
Caption: and everyone thought this was a very
Caption: outlandish thing to say but javale louis
Caption: said that that in a good service
Caption: oriented architecture every class would
Caption: be a service
Caption: and everyone laughed so this was a
Caption: ridiculous thing to say but we've kind
Caption: of ended up here
Caption: again this is my grumpy old man showing
Caption: so what happens is you know software
Caption: there's a couple of
Caption: principles of good software design
Caption: around um like loose coupling and and
Caption: cohesion and
Caption: the software to collaborate within its
Caption: design needs you know cohesion and if
Caption: we've split it too far apart then all of
Caption: a sudden you know
Caption: we're talking too much over you know
Caption: http
Caption: and
Caption: you know then you have to deal with
Caption: distributed computing
Caption: a lot you know because software is
Caption: cohesive all these things talk to each
Caption: other and if all of a sudden you're
Caption: talking to each other over a network
Caption: boundary then you know again you've got
Caption: all sorts of problems
Caption: and so what i see is services just are
Caption: way too chatty does anyone kind of work
Caption: on microservices architecture that's
Caption: just way too chatty
Caption: because then you bring in more
Caption: infrastructure you bring in you know
Caption: istio and
Caption: um
Caption: side car services and service meshes and
Caption: things like that to solve the fact that
Caption: we've just split our design way too
Caption: early and our boundaries are done
Caption: way way too early
Caption: so some of the symptoms of that
Caption: when you see it is
Caption: massive amounts of shared code
Caption: so then we go okay all of our services
Caption: need the same classes in there so okay
Caption: we need a mono repo or or worse still we
Caption: have everything in one giant solution
Caption: and i've seen that like 20 micro
Caption: services in one visual studio solution
Caption: because they need
Caption: so much shared code
Caption: and then you have back to the problem
Caption: that we had in you know the early 2000s
Caption: which is you need to deploy everything
Caption: in exactly the same order
Caption: because you've got four services with
Caption: the same classes and if those classes
Caption: don't match
Caption: you've got all sorts of errors so then
Caption: you know everything has to be deployed
Caption: at exactly the same times they're not
Caption: autonomous anymore
Caption: um when i was at octopus deploy one of
Caption: the things that we did at octopus and
Caption: they still do is pretty much everyone
Caption: does a rotation on customer support
Caption: which is if you've never done it it's an
Caption: amazing way to develop empathy for your
Caption: customer
Caption: and you make design decisions and then
Caption: see the impact of that by figuring out
Caption: what's hard for people to do and where
Caption: they get it wrong it's an amazingly
Caption: amazing process for kind of building
Caption: empathy when you're within your team
Caption: so people would would write in or email
Caption: in
Caption: write in
Caption: and they'd say octopus doesn't support
Caption: microservices
Caption: what do you mean it's like we have all
Caption: of our services each one's its own
Caption: project but we need all the projects to
Caption: be deployed at exactly the same time
Caption: right
Caption: so what this gets snarkily called is you
Caption: don't have microservices you have a
Caption: distributed monolith
Caption: which is kind of the worst of
Caption: the worst of all of those worlds um
Caption: and then again we start adding
Caption: infrastructure to it
Caption: so
Caption: for those of you who got through 15
Caption: chapters of the domain driven design
Caption: book
Caption: there's a concept called a bounded
Caption: context
Caption: and
Caption: again this is a book about modeling and
Caption: and you start speaking to experts within
Caption: the business and you develop a shared
Caption: vocabulary and
Caption: in chapter 15 of the domain driven
Caption: design book
Caption: eric evans says that if you start to
Caption: notice that
Caption: different groups of people in the
Caption: business start using words differently
Caption: or talking about something with a
Caption: different phrase that's a bounded
Caption: context yeah
Caption: um
Caption: and you find that you know if anyone
Caption: sort of worked in a in a big
Caption: organization you might say well this
Caption: thing is an order but an order to
Caption: somebody else is a completely different
Caption: concept someone felt felt that one yep
Caption: so the best example of this i've heard
Caption: um was from a guy named dan north who
Caption: was also sort works and and he
Caption: overtalked
Caption: a bunch of years ago
Caption: that i'm going to
Caption: steal shamelessly
Caption: where he talked about going on holiday
Caption: and he has this this concept of okay i'm
Caption: going on holiday um
Caption: your view of your holiday might be a a
Caption: postcard
Caption: or or you know a website or a magazine
Caption: article
Caption: where you've got
Caption: beach you know white sandy beach
Caption: cocktail umbrella you know snorkeling
Caption: whatever it is that's your i'm going on
Caption: holiday i'm really stressed i need to go
Caption: and sit on the beach okay that's your
Caption: view of a holiday
Caption: but to get there you need to do a few
Caption: things you need to put in a leave
Caption: request okay so your hr department
Caption: needs to think about your holiday now
Caption: your hr department's view of your
Caption: holiday is not like sandy beaches and a
Caption: cocktail with an umbrella in it um
Caption: your hr's view of your holiday is do you
Caption: have enough leave days
Caption: that kind of thing how many hours have
Caption: you accrued you might also have to get
Caption: that signed off by your manager
Caption: your manager's view of your holiday
Caption: might be well actually we have this
Caption: project deadline we've got our legacy
Caption: system replacement it's due to go live
Caption: next month no you can't go on holiday
Caption: which is exactly why you need to go on
Caption: holiday um
Caption: you might call a travel agent to you
Caption: know book you a flight um and a hotel so
Caption: they're gonna have a completely
Caption: different set of words and different
Caption: like lens and different framing of your
Caption: holiday it's all the same thing
Caption: but everybody has a completely different
Caption: set of terminology and way of thinking
Caption: about framing your holiday and and
Caption: that's about a context yeah
Caption: so
Caption: so bounded context around the people
Caption: involved in something and and the
Caption: interactions with it
Caption: okay so
Caption: if you think about building services you
Caption: can start to use that framing around
Caption: water services so if you've got a
Caption: bounded context you know well we look at
Caption: this thing and it means this to us
Caption: that might be a really good place to
Caption: start with a service yeah
Caption: and then what you can do is model the
Caption: communication across the people in this
Caption: organization and
Caption: how they communicate that stuff and that
Caption: becomes in a really good shape of of
Caption: what your service looks like and what
Caption: that sort of bounded context looks like
Caption: so you know
Caption: um
Caption: if somebody says in your organization
Caption: go do this
Caption: that's a that's called a command
Caption: or if somebody else sits there and they
Caption: wait for wait to be told about something
Caption: that's an event and we can start to
Caption: model then commands and events and
Caption: requests within an organization
Caption: so
Caption: to put an example on that
Caption: think about
Caption: a really bad restaurant
Caption: imagine turning up to a restaurant and
Caption: you sit down with your friends
Caption: and
Caption: a waiter comes up with a menu board with
Caption: no prices on it
Caption: let's go here are the things
Caption: and you'd say
Caption: um
Caption: how much is the burger and they just run
Caption: away
Caption: and come back and go that's you know 12
Caption: and you go
Caption: i'll have a burger thanks and they go
Caption: okay
Caption: i'll just check if we have them
Caption: and they run back into the kitchen come
Caption: back and go yes you can have a burger
Caption: and like cool well i'd like the burger
Caption: thanks um and we'd also like the fish
Caption: and like hang on
Caption: and they run back
Caption: into the kitchen a few minutes later
Caption: come back and we don't have fish
Caption: and
Caption: so you're frustrating that well can we
Caption: have some pizza they run back in and
Caption: they go through this process of like
Caption: running back in and checking if they
Caption: have it for all of the food and all of
Caption: the drinks for every single person at
Caption: the table
Caption: and then you go okay got the order right
Caption: i would like that and they go cool that
Caption: will cost this
Caption: well we haven't eaten yet but you know
Caption: okay here's the card and they walk and
Caption: they stand in line behind all the other
Caption: staff in one line to get to the one fps
Caption: machine payment gateways are hard and
Caption: eventually they get there
Caption: process your card and it's declined so
Caption: they come back and go that card was
Caption: declined you're ah that's right gotta
Caption: put money on that account you transfer
Caption: some money over and they go and get back
Caption: in the line
Caption: and you're sitting there at this point
Caption: you're hungry you're grumpy
Caption: because this order still hasn't gone to
Caption: the kitchen because you haven't paid for
Caption: it yet they come back and go yes that
Caption: was successful and then they go into the
Caption: kitchen to place your order and then
Caption: just disappear you don't see them again
Caption: for a long time
Caption: and you realize that all the white staff
Caption: are walking into the kitchen
Caption: and not coming out until they have the
Caption: food
Caption: yeah so eventually your waiter comes out
Caption: um
Caption: gives you food and you and you eat the
Caption: field eat the meal at that point you
Caption: know you're having a bad time it's not
Caption: it's not a great dining experience one
Caption: star would not do again
Caption: um and this company is not going to last
Caption: too long because they're going to need
Caption: way too many staff
Caption: they're going to go through the staff
Caption: because everyone's rude to them
Caption: and it just it's not going to scale
Caption: right
Caption: has anyone been to this restaurant it
Caption: sounds pretty bad
Caption: this is how we build systems this is how
Caption: a lot of people build software um
Caption: because you know coming back to this
Caption: kind of
Caption: sort of canonical microservice
Caption: architecture that you see it looks like
Caption: this
Caption: and we've got all these http requests
Caption: now what's something about http requests
Caption: they're synchronous
Caption: okay and so we build this stuff and this
Caption: is kind of how we build this restaurant
Caption: like i would like to do this i will go
Caption: check the pricing service like literally
Caption: every micro service kind of beginning
Caption: article has a cart service and a pricing
Caption: service
Caption: and that's like the way to holding the
Caption: board and then going have to ask the
Caption: manager how much the burger is
Caption: and it's bad this is how we build
Caption: systems
Caption: so
Caption: let's think about a better restaurant
Caption: you walk in you sit down the staff hands
Caption: you out some menus the menus have prices
Caption: on the menus have specials on them
Caption: because somebody sat down when those
Caption: prices changed created a menu and put it
Caption: on there you sit down and they go
Caption: actually look i just the kitchen just
Caption: told me we've just run out of fish so
Caption: that one's not in there you know okay
Caption: cool that's fine i'll order something
Caption: else
Caption: you sit there and you go and here's the
Caption: order and the stuff you know right the
Caption: food on one slip and the drinks on
Caption: another slip and
Caption: they you know take one slip to the
Caption: kitchen another one to the bar and your
Caption: orders in all easy
Caption: and then after a few minutes um
Caption: bell rings at the kitchen
Caption: okay and some staff go over to see what
Caption: the bell was for it's like okay table
Caption: ten food's ready and they bring
Caption: to your table and you sit down and eat
Caption: it
Caption: and
Caption: when it's time to go you go up and you
Caption: pay like to pay for table 10 again you
Caption: might still have the f problem but it's
Caption: easy you know just just kind of solve it
Caption: and meanwhile you've got a restaurant
Caption: manager who's sitting there kind of
Caption: overseeing like this table got their
Caption: food on time is anyone waiting too long
Caption: is everything kind of working as it is
Caption: right
Caption: that's a better restaurant because
Caption: you've got
Caption: um
Caption: it's it's fewer staff and they're
Caption: getting more done
Caption: because
Caption: they're not relying on waiting for
Caption: answers all the time
Caption: they take your order into the kitchen
Caption: they say
Caption: make this
Caption: yeah
Caption: and when it's ready someone rings a belt
Caption: and they come and get it
Caption: one's a command
Caption: another one's an event yeah
Caption: and so
Caption: the way these like it's the same
Caption: activities they're still ordering food
Caption: and they're still cooking food and
Caption: they're still bringing still paying but
Caption: it's the way those activities are
Caption: are grouped and who's in charge of it
Caption: and how the communication happens is
Caption: better modeling yeah does anyone go and
Caption: watch businesses and just like think
Caption: about the systems you know like
Caption: massively into systems thinking and you
Caption: look at that and go if that person did
Caption: that job everything would go better yeah
Caption: it's great great people watching
Caption: i can't help myself um and and it's
Caption: modeling right
Caption: and so in this restaurant the staff know
Caption: when something's run out
Caption: they've got the prices of stuff
Caption: the kitchen knows when to make something
Caption: you don't have
Caption: a waiter standing in the kitchen going
Caption: is it ready yet is it ready yet is it
Caption: ready yet is it ready yet is it ready
Caption: yet you know someone rings a bell okay
Caption: good modeling and this is a good
Caption: restaurant you leave from this
Caption: good experience five star would eat
Caption: again
Caption: so
Caption: what can we take from this
Caption: chains of requests do not scale well
Caption: yeah they're not worked in a company
Caption: where to get anything done you have to
Caption: ask your manager and they asked their
Caption: manager and then they asked kind of a
Caption: sideways and it goes down and you're
Caption: sitting there and you're like couldn't
Caption: i've just gone and talked to them
Caption: it doesn't scale um it's not a fun place
Caption: to work
Caption: the chains of requests do not scale
Caption: there's not a way to get things done
Caption: people that have the information to do
Caption: their job are a lot more effective at it
Caption: um again these are kind of fairly
Caption: commonly known things
Caption: but software
Caption: boundaries that follow these same
Caption: principles tend to work better and a lot
Caption: of it is around synchronicity so you
Caption: know synchronous things where you're
Caption: waiting for an answer don't scale and
Caption: don't kind of work as well as things
Caption: that are asynchronous
Caption: again
Caption: ring the bell the food's ready
Caption: so
Caption: applying this to services if a service
Caption: knows enough to do its job
Caption: then it's going to scale better it's
Caption: going to work better so
Caption: i have a i have a cute name for this
Caption: which is human shaped microservices
Caption: trademark
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um
Caption: so you know when i look at it when i
Caption: look at a a software system and kind of
Caption: try to bring it down to well if people
Caption: were doing it
Caption: who would the people be what would they
Caption: be in charge of um how would they do
Caption: that thing and how would they
Caption: communicate it so what would people do
Caption: if we were building this system out of
Caption: people and
Caption: again synchronous chains of people
Caption: asking a question going what's the
Caption: answer what's the answer what's the
Caption: answer it's not a good it's not you know
Caption: an effective business to to be in so you
Caption: look at well if you're going to group
Caption: this and have people doing those jobs
Caption: how would you organize that company to
Caption: be effective
Caption: and
Caption: then build the systems the same way
Caption: so a really good technique for this
Caption: something called event storming has
Caption: anyone seen event storming some kind of
Caption: a modeling technique where you
Caption: get post-it notes on a board and
Caption: and you say well
Caption: if we were doing this you know i would
Caption: tell the kitchen to make these things
Caption: and that's a command and then the
Caption: kitchen would say this order is ready
Caption: that's an event and you kind of with
Caption: different colored sticky notes
Caption: stick them all on a board with these are
Caption: the commands and these are the events
Caption: and then figure out what talks to what
Caption: and why and you end up with a really
Caption: good mapping of the way an organization
Caption: should work
Caption: and
Caption: then build the software around that so
Caption: again
Caption: commands and events work really well
Caption: here
Caption: i'm going to quickly talk about kind of
Caption: the tech of that um because often like
Caption: people sort of tend to think about um
Caption: micro services as you know just rest
Caption: um but i actually really like messaging
Caption: for a lot of this stuff
Caption: because it maps really quite well
Caption: so http is a synchronous
Caption: transport you know that's about
Caption: requesting a document and getting
Caption: something back
Caption: and what we've learned is synchronous
Caption: calls will reduce your reliability
Caption: and they reduce your ability to scale
Caption: and you have to deploy stuff at exactly
Caption: the right time because it's not
Caption: something there you know it gets hard
Caption: so
Caption: you can still use http to model commands
Caption: and events if you want but it ends up
Caption: being a bunch more work you might have a
Caption: table of events and then you know all
Caption: the other services have to kind of poll
Caption: that table and keep a cursor and it's
Caption: extra database stuff so messaging kind
Caption: of works really really well for this um
Caption: you know for this for this style of
Caption: thing because you can you can put a
Caption: command on a queue
Caption: oh
Caption: sorry
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: yeah you can have pub sub and and
Caption: messaging systems work really really
Caption: well for micro services
Caption: rest is still a great api service
Caption: particularly on the web like the web is
Caption: built around http we've got cdns we've
Caption: got proxies you know like it's a it's a
Caption: really good protocol there's lots of
Caption: semantics built into it
Caption: into http and then you sort of apply a
Caption: rest style on top of that that's a whole
Caption: other discussion um
Caption: you know hypertext is a good thing like
Caption: a lot of the web is built on that and
Caption: scales really really well
Caption: so i have a pattern that i've had a lot
Caption: of success with that again
Caption: as a joke one day i call it mullet micro
Caption: services
Caption: um because it's got rest on the front
Caption: and messaging in the back
Caption: and people seem to like that so i'm i'm
Caption: sticking with it um but this is a
Caption: pattern i've had a lot of success with
Caption: um even in sort of replacing legacy
Caption: systems where you can build services
Caption: um behind a load balancer yeah
Caption: but their back plane the way they
Caption: communicate to each other is um through
Caption: messages from a message broker or you
Caption: know something like that
Caption: and i'm running out of time really
Caption: quickly some conclusions um
Caption: from all of this is
Caption: learn from history like you want to set
Caption: out to to use a new technique or a new
Caption: tool or a piece of infrastructure or
Caption: patent or whatever it is
Caption: understand that idea and what led to it
Caption: like what problem
Caption: was being solved when somebody created
Caption: this thing
Caption: what caused that problem that they were
Caption: trying to
Caption: what caused that
Caption: understand the history of in context of
Caption: how we got there
Caption: and doing that would just make you a
Caption: better technologist like we're going to
Caption: use this thing and it was designed to
Caption: solve this problem we have that problem
Caption: it's a good fit if it's we want to do
Caption: that because it's on hacker news and
Caption: it's really cool you're going to be a
Caption: less effective technologist
Caption: another takeaway is microservices and so
Caption: i kind of have the same routes and the
Caption: same problems they're about if you go
Caption: back and read sort of the the early
Caption: stuff around sower it's about services
Caption: that are loosely coupled and
Caption: autonomously manage a business process
Caption: and micro services are kind of the same
Caption: but a bit smaller but essentially the
Caption: principles are there
Caption: and you know if we sort of don't like
Caption: autonomously manage that business
Caption: process they get super chatty
Caption: in modeling look at the people business
Caption: processes how would people do that model
Caption: your software after that and then the
Caption: main one is never forget that actually
Caption: delivering value is the goal
Caption: um that's what we're here for that's the
Caption: smart bit like your job isn't well i you
Caption: know bring containers to an organization
Caption: your job is about
Caption: you know delivering value whether that's
Caption: selling something customers or solving
Caption: the internal problem whatever it is
Caption: that's the goal
Caption: and we get way too caught up in that
Caption: so yeah with that i'm going to do a
Caption: quick plug
Caption: which is i'm teaching this stuff um and
Caption: if anyone wants to come and talk to me
Caption: about that i would love to have that
Caption: chat
Caption: essentially i've seen this enough times
Caption: that i'm like what can i do about this
Caption: so i actually want to teach it you know
Caption: teach this stuff and get hands on but i
Caption: don't want to make it too much of a plug
Caption: with that we're getting low on time
Caption: any questions and i'm happy to i'm happy
Caption: for you to accost me all day and and
Caption: chat about this stuff but any questions
Caption: in the room
Caption: thanks for that that was great mate um i
Caption: work in a medium-sized organization that
Caption: was that's now integrating with a very
Caption: large
Caption: organization um
Caption: what are the kind of
Caption: i guess cultural preconditions for
Caption: microservices and especially in an
Caption: organization that's already on the
Caption: journey but
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah that's a that's a tricky one and i
Caption: like honestly i've not seen a
Caption: one-size-fits-all
Caption: to that um the biggest problem seems to
Caption: be in those
Caption: those journeys and those organizations
Caption: is that
Caption: it's very hard to get anything started
Caption: because they're so risk adverse that no
Caption: one ever wants to fail so it's you know
Caption: and i've seen this in a big organization
Caption: where it's like we want to do this thing
Caption: very simple and they're like you can't
Caption: do that because we are still figuring
Caption: out
Caption: what our container strategy is or what
Caption: our messaging strategy is or and then
Caption: you've got you know a team of enterprise
Caption: architects that will take 12 months to
Caption: make a ruling on something before you
Caption: can touch it and it's all very like oh
Caption: and that's super hard
Caption: if you're in that organization and you
Caption: can ship
Caption: then
Caption: um
Caption: yeah just do small things quickly um and
Caption: again you know in in sort of technical
Caption: stuff http is great like you don't want
Caption: to expose like you've got you know
Caption: active mq or like a message broker back
Caption: there you probably don't want to expose
Caption: that because you want to change your
Caption: semantics so if you go well this is our
Caption: boundary is an api that people can
Caption: request and treat it like a third party
Caption: um
Caption: yeah we'd love to hear more about it
Caption: later it's a yeah
Caption: it's a tricky one
Caption: sorry everyone um damian's being called
Caption: to the speaker photo now oh yeah we're
Caption: gonna have to gotta go get my photo talk
Caption: i'm sure though you can yes i'll be down
Caption: later yeah
Caption: yeah also if you don't want to come talk
Caption: to me damian m on twitter if you'd like
Caption: to tweet at me happy to do it um thank
Caption: you everyone so much
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: do
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: friends i'm scott hanselman and i was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: mark where are you mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you
Caption: want god
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now
Caption: folks know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: hi everyone
Caption: thanks for joining us
Caption: so today we have boris badroth
Caption: uh his dev by day and also kite surfer
Caption: by day otherwise pretending to be a chef
Caption: by cooking whatever dish he found on
Caption: youtube next up is boris badroth and his
Caption: indexing story
Caption: cool
Caption: hello
Caption: hello all right cool coming through all
Caption: right
Caption: it's all right
Caption: um is that coming through yep cool all
Caption: right hey guys i'm boris so um i'm an
Caption: engineer at bgw i've been working in the
Caption: industry for roughly four years
Caption: and for the majority of their experience
Caption: um
Caption: i've known indexes as they make a
Caption: database go fast and that was the extent
Caption: of my knowledge
Caption: so we had some issues with an
Caption: application that i was working on and it
Caption: was oh okay we're gonna use an index
Caption: so i got compelled hey let's figure out
Caption: what this is
Caption: so today what are we learning when we
Caption: learn about indexes how do they work
Caption: indexing techniques and how to debug
Caption: indexes
Caption: so this will be going off postgres's
Caption: implementation of indexes but this is
Caption: relatively a high level talk so the
Caption: concepts should translate over to other
Caption: databases as well
Caption: um shout out to the sponsors today for
Caption: making today possible and also to the
Caption: volunteers and the av team or everything
Caption: for keeping everything organized
Caption: right
Caption: today
Caption: we are doing some work we i
Caption: are a website recipe aggregator we get
Caption: something like reddit hack news we get
Caption: recipes from other places and we display
Caption: them for everyone to see
Caption: cool so we're working with product we're
Caption: working on a future we're going to be
Caption: generating some reports with some
Caption: queries essentially so we're going to be
Caption: working with one table today it looks
Caption: something like this
Caption: it's quite straightforward um if you're
Caption: not sure generated always as identity
Caption: means it just is an incrementing number
Caption: that the database does automatically for
Caption: you so it's always going to be unique
Caption: and some example data that we have here
Caption: minutes is in
Caption: cooking times in minutes as well
Caption: and yes we've got roughly around a
Caption: million rows today so it's not a huge
Caption: table but it's decent enough to
Caption: illustrate
Caption: so we're working with product the first
Caption: feature we want it uses our query
Caption: something like this
Caption: which is somewhat straightforward
Caption: let's do some testing so dev is okay
Caption: cool
Caption: let's go to prod
Caption: now let's deploy
Caption: huh
Caption: it didn't work right i wonder why
Caption: let's revert the change let's go back
Caption: and let's talk about what what do we
Caption: just do
Caption: i'm going to give you a cooking book and
Caption: i want you to keep this for the rest of
Caption: the talk so i ask you hey can i can you
Caption: find me all recipes of garlic go through
Caption: the book we go okay g sorry not g you go
Caption: through the book you have to go through
Caption: the whole book page by page by page by
Caption: page
Caption: all the way to the end because you don't
Caption: know maybe that last page has a recipe
Caption: with garlic but you don't know so you
Caption: have to go through the entire book so
Caption: that's called a sequential scan
Caption: so we do a bit of googling and obviously
Caption: i'm here to talk to you about indexes so
Caption: let's use an index let's get this over
Caption: and done with
Caption: i get the syntax that overflow tells me
Caption: this is correct i will always trust them
Caption: obviously
Caption: cool
Caption: davis again fine let's go to prod it's
Caption: done easy okay
Caption: well
Caption: what do we just do
Caption: so again cookbook
Caption: i give you the cookbook and conveniently
Caption: it has a thing well called an index
Caption: right which translates to databases so
Caption: go to the index go down you go to g find
Caption: garlic and you find all the recipes that
Caption: have garlic and then you have the page
Caption: numbers and then you can go to the book
Caption: and you find all the recipes that have
Caption: garlic much quicker than going through
Caption: the whole book
Caption: so something like so
Caption: we have two recipes with garlic chicken
Caption: roast and garlic bread on pages 800 and
Caption: pages 6.
Caption: so before i explain databases let's talk
Caption: a little bit about ferry what what is an
Caption: index well in this case so there's a few
Caption: different types of indexes here
Caption: default is b3 um and i think it's every
Caption: database is but it's the fault of b3
Caption: there's a whole bunch of others but
Caption: they're very complicated i'm not going
Caption: to cover them so b3
Caption: what does it look like
Caption: okay so at the top we have the root note
Caption: at the bottom we have the leaf nodes
Caption: and you can notice it's kind of ordered
Caption: with the smallest numbers at the left
Caption: biggest numbers at the right
Caption: and b tree is balance free not a binary
Caption: tree
Caption: so searching
Caption: uh
Caption: searching insertion and deletion is all
Caption: log in as long as it remains balanced
Caption: database will do that for you so you
Caption: don't need to worry about that balance
Caption: meaning from the root node the top node
Caption: to the bottom node for all root uh
Caption: bottom nodes is the same amount of nodes
Caption: to climb up that means it's balance
Caption: so say searching i want to find value
Caption: 999 which is at the bottom so i start at
Caption: the root node
Caption: 999 is greater than 800
Caption: so we go to 900. 999 is greater than 900
Caption: so we go to 999. ta-da found our value
Caption: okay
Caption: so how's it working well how does this
Caption: actually work right so remember we had
Caption: the cookbook bring the index so in
Caption: database world we went and found our
Caption: value
Caption: of one one one
Caption: and what it had there essentially is
Caption: well you can look at it as has a row id
Caption: and that row id is actually the database
Caption: id and it goes to this row id i'm sorry
Caption: it gets the one one one it gives us
Caption: variety then actually goes back to the
Caption: table and gets the rest of the
Caption: information which is a lot faster than
Caption: you know sequentially scanning and it's
Caption: kind of like the cookbook you don't have
Caption: the whole recipe in the index you just
Caption: have go to this page number and go find
Caption: it
Caption: so
Caption: enough theory oh it's kind of boring
Caption: let's make this quite practical
Caption: tell me what the index
Caption: okay
Caption: let's do something really generic
Caption: wear or join index it your primary keys
Caption: you need constraints will be
Caption: automatically indexed
Caption: but like everything else in software
Caption: well it's not that straightforward
Caption: obviously so the
Caption: point i'm going to hammer in today is
Caption: know your queries know your queries are
Caption: expensive or long-running the most
Caption: executed queries and your most important
Caption: queries that will give you the starting
Caption: ground when uh where to create your
Caption: indexes
Caption: so that comes kind of to the next point
Caption: well why not just index all the indexes
Caption: right want to just do absolutely
Caption: everything
Caption: well there's trade-offs with indexes
Caption: let's think the cookbook we did a very
Caption: simple one index on ingredient but let's
Caption: say i then do cuisine i do category i do
Caption: the maybe the chef
Caption: how long it takes
Caption: and your index is just going to keep
Caption: going in size and keep going in size and
Caption: now your index is bigger than the book
Caption: so it came kind of useless
Caption: and you have to think okay there's also
Caption: insertions so let's imagine a book again
Caption: if i tell you hey um here's a new recipe
Caption: with garlic and you go okay sure you put
Caption: that recipe in your book you update your
Caption: book with this recipe and then you have
Caption: to go to the index and update the index
Caption: as well so this is if you have too many
Caption: indexes it's just going to get longer
Caption: and longer and longer in short
Caption: indexes give you increased read speed
Caption: decreased write speed
Caption: so
Caption: now you might think okay well why not
Caption: okay we know that we shouldn't index
Caption: everything but how do i know i don't
Caption: want to risk like
Caption: having a poor performance you know your
Caption: company's going to start losing money
Caption: it's not really nice to deploy something
Caption: sit there waiting anxiously is it going
Caption: to be okay or not
Caption: so again know your queries
Caption: do your queries need to be fast
Caption: um and what are they for so
Caption: announcements they're for reports are
Caption: reports time critical do they need to
Caption: actually execute instantly
Caption: generally i'd say no i mean for the
Caption: purposes of talk we want them but um in
Caption: that case no do you ever read replica
Caption: maybe like a database that can bear the
Caption: extra load of reading well then
Caption: maybe you don't need them
Caption: now when it comes to say application do
Caption: you have observer observability and
Caption: alerting on your application that can
Caption: indicate poor performance
Caption: do you have a way to deploy this feature
Caption: to a small small subset of customers
Caption: first and see what's going on before
Caption: making a call to apply to everyone if
Caption: you have something like that then you
Caption: can hold off on pre-indexing but again
Caption: it comes down to knowing your queries
Caption: how much data is there
Caption: alrighty so more work time which means
Caption: more indexes to create
Caption: but
Caption: there's a few caveats here so first
Caption: thing you might have noticed
Caption: dave was okay but prod wasn't there's
Caption: quite a few factors that come to effect
Caption: this sort of thing
Caption: first of all is a hardware that your
Caption: database is running on is going to
Caption: influence your results
Caption: um the volume of data so generally
Caption: you're going to have a smaller
Caption: set of data locally or in div compared
Caption: to prod and the distribution
Caption: distribution of data is also extremely
Caption: important as well
Caption: um
Caption: so that is something to keep in mind
Caption: when you're
Caption: when you have indexes in different
Caption: environments and stuff like that and
Caption: even some of these results today you'll
Caption: see
Caption: um a bit skewed because i've just put
Caption: this data on my machine
Caption: okay
Caption: so first thing i want to cover is
Caption: creating index is the correct way so i
Caption: showed you this but
Caption: you're never going to do this because
Caption: this locks the database against writes
Caption: to that table which in production at
Caption: least my experience that's usually well
Caption: not very good so we add it concurrently
Caption: and what this does is
Caption: does a scan with a table
Caption: and doesn't lock that doesn't lock it
Caption: gets everything and it kind of does it
Caption: again afterwards to get capture all the
Caption: missing transactions from before
Caption: it's very high level it gets a bit more
Caption: complicated than that but that's the
Caption: gist of it and there are queries that
Caption: you can actually run to see is your
Caption: index still being created or not
Caption: um it's long and it's ugly google it if
Caption: you want it but that's the gist of it
Caption: okay
Caption: before we do some work we also have to
Caption: talk about debugging so the cool thing
Caption: databases is you can go to and say hey
Caption: what do you think you're going to do and
Caption: then you can also tell hey what are you
Caption: going to do um what are what did you
Caption: actually do and then you can compare
Caption: them and make judgment calls on that
Caption: so in postgres we prefix our query with
Caption: explain
Caption: and that's essentially time postgres hey
Caption: what do you think you're going to do
Caption: here now i might be thinking okay
Caption: how does it know what it thinks it's
Caption: going to do
Caption: this is a very complicated topic and
Caption: finally put this is a talk on its own
Caption: it's i went on a bit of a rabbit hole in
Caption: this and it's absolutely incredible how
Caption: it does it uses all sorts of statistics
Caption: and stored in the table to make these
Caption: calls
Caption: so let's look at what this kind of looks
Caption: like
Caption: so
Caption: at the top we have you can see here cost
Caption: that first number
Caption: is the cost to find the first node our
Caption: first row
Caption: then the next number which is 13 000
Caption: something something something that's the
Caption: cost to find all rows what it estimates
Caption: to be
Caption: the funny part about this and this is a
Caption: quote from the post documentation might
Caption: be thinking okay what does that number
Caption: represent
Caption: it's an arbitrary unit so it differs on
Caption: your laptop and a bunch of things there
Caption: is a long formula uses like the hardware
Caption: your laptop your computer all sorts of
Caption: stuff to try and figure it out
Caption: so it's not particularly useful you
Caption: could say
Caption: then we have how many rows that things
Caption: match this condition and the width of
Caption: each row which is in bytes if i remember
Caption: correctly
Caption: and then we could see it did a parallel
Caption: sequential scan
Caption: which is what we talked about before
Caption: which isn't good and it's going to do
Caption: that twice because 45 times 2 is roughly
Caption: that
Caption: and then a filter
Caption: then with the index scan it's kind of
Caption: similar nothing too different than the
Caption: important part here we can see it says
Caption: index scan
Caption: so
Caption: well let's do something a bit more
Caption: interesting here
Caption: let's see
Caption: what it actually does
Caption: okay so now we're prefix to explain
Caption: analyze analyze will tell hey can you
Caption: run the query too please so we can
Caption: compare
Caption: and what you can see here is after say
Caption: on the top line after the gather we have
Caption: another one which says actual time
Caption: that's in milliseconds
Caption: so that's the time it takes to find the
Caption: first row that matches the condition and
Caption: the time to find all rows of matching
Caption: condition
Caption: and then we'll parallel sequential scan
Caption: how long it took
Caption: and then we can see here is remote rows
Caption: removed by filter that's an interesting
Caption: part here
Caption: two lines above says loops three so
Caption: that's times three
Caption: that filtered out the vast majority of
Caption: the table so we generally say that's an
Caption: absolute ideal candidate for an index
Caption: when we see something like this
Caption: and this took 33 milliseconds
Caption: now
Caption: let's see how fast it indexes
Caption: whoops
Caption: it was 11.8 milliseconds so that was a
Caption: third of the time of the sequential scan
Caption: and we can see it says index scans
Caption: before we have all the stuff
Caption: as well index condition but i just want
Caption: to highlight
Caption: the time that it took and how much
Caption: faster i was
Caption: okay so
Caption: now we've done a little bit of very very
Caption: high level of the query planner let's do
Caption: some more work let's see if we can learn
Caption: more about this so now product design
Caption: says hey we don't just want author id we
Caption: also want source id which is where we're
Caption: getting that because we're aggregated
Caption: we're getting these these recipes from
Caption: different sources and stuff like that so
Caption: our query is going to be something like
Caption: so
Caption: okay cool
Caption: you can see here we did this with no
Caption: index and
Caption: we can see 27 milliseconds and obviously
Caption: it's going to filter a lot more rows
Caption: this time there's only 12 rows in
Caption: matching condition which is right at the
Caption: top
Caption: to the right
Caption: cool alrighty
Caption: so we create an index and
Caption: you can see here it's multi-column index
Caption: the order that you specify the columns
Caption: here
Caption: is extremely important and i'm going to
Caption: explain a little bit more but let's
Caption: first see how fast this is
Caption: so from 27 milliseconds to 0.2
Caption: milliseconds
Caption: that is lightning fast that is a pretty
Caption: huge change so that's quite nice right
Caption: let's talk about how i said the order so
Caption: we said
Caption: multi-column index first second i said
Caption: indexes are ordered so what does that
Caption: mean
Caption: well if i
Caption: create an index on author id and source
Caption: id what it kind of looks like is if i go
Caption: to one one one
Caption: let's use the cookbook example i go to
Caption: this the id of one one one one i find it
Caption: then inside of it it's all going to be
Caption: ordered by the source id
Caption: okay cool what does this mean
Caption: practically okay so we create this
Caption: multi-column index
Caption: and if i want to query on authority
Caption: source id it works fine because i can go
Caption: to one one one and other than that i
Caption: have 40 right
Caption: if i want to do just on author id that's
Caption: going to work too because well it's
Caption: ordered first by author id right
Caption: but if i ask if i write a query and it's
Caption: like hey can you get it by just source
Caption: id well
Caption: no that's not going to work because
Caption: think of the book it's ordered by
Caption: authorities at 111 you have a bunch of
Caption: other ids there within the source side
Caption: is if i want to find 40 i'm going to
Caption: have to scan every single author and
Caption: find 40. at that point the index is
Caption: useless you might as well just do a
Caption: sequential scan
Caption: cool
Caption: so what are the other options we can
Caption: databases are cool you can create two
Caption: single column indexes and it will
Caption: combine them for you automatically which
Caption: is pretty incredible
Caption: okay
Caption: i've skipped something here
Caption: selectivity and cardinality are two
Caption: concepts and indexes are extremely
Caption: important so what are they selectivity
Caption: is
Caption: give it a a
Caption: a value for um that you're searching for
Caption: how many rows does it return as a
Caption: proportion of the table something like
Caption: recipe id which is the primary key so
Caption: it's unique it's going to have a very
Caption: high selectivity because realistically
Caption: there's going to be one row with it
Caption: then you have cardinality and
Caption: cardinality is
Caption: given a value how many um given a column
Caption: how many possible values are there for a
Caption: column so maybe for something like
Caption: source id
Caption: that's going to be a lower cardinality
Caption: if we have maybe 10 sources that we
Caption: always get
Caption: something like recipe id or arthrity
Caption: will have a very high cardinality
Caption: because there's a lot of possible values
Caption: well okay
Caption: why is this important
Caption: essentially
Caption: forgive my absolutely beautiful diagram
Caption: but
Caption: when you search on something like source
Caption: id let's imagine that source id returns
Caption: roughly half of the table
Caption: okay remember i said it's a two-step
Caption: processor you go to the index
Caption: from the index you get the rest of the
Caption: information
Caption: if i'm going to be going through a ha if
Caption: i'm getting half the values that's half
Caption: the index or half the table
Caption: what's the point going the index that's
Caption: just going to be slower i might as well
Caption: just go directly to the table and that's
Caption: what a database will do
Caption: the rule of thumb generally is um
Caption: if you're returning more than 10 to 15
Caption: of your table your index is not going to
Caption: be any good
Caption: okay
Caption: know your queries so what does this mean
Caption: we've covered we have the multi-column
Caption: index which is quite fast we saw
Caption: we can combine the indexes but we can't
Caption: actually because source id an index on
Caption: source id is kind of useless um it's
Caption: pointless it's not selective enough okay
Caption: so
Caption: this is where we think what are our
Caption: queries okay so
Caption: and source id
Caption: how often are we going to be querying
Caption: author id and then something else
Caption: we talk to product we look at our code
Caption: and we see we do it quite a bit actually
Caption: we do source uh authority and number
Caption: radiance and quite a few bunch of others
Caption: so we're not we can't just create a
Caption: whole bunch of multi-column indexes
Caption: because that's pretty inefficient right
Caption: that's kind of a waste essentially well
Caption: there's a decent middle ground here
Caption: which is just create an index on
Caption: authority and that will be flexible it
Caption: will serve all your queries and
Caption: oops it's going to be relatively fast
Caption: it's still going to be 0.9 milliseconds
Caption: versus 0.2 keeping in mind without the
Caption: index at all it was 28 milliseconds
Caption: that's still
Caption: really fast essentially
Caption: and what you see here what it does is we
Caption: go to our book i go to the author id 1 1
Caption: 1 i grab all the values there and then i
Caption: filter all the values out that don't
Caption: meet the source id of
Caption: 40.
Caption: cool all right
Caption: so
Caption: more work
Caption: we want popular recipes for an author
Caption: okay kind of submitted before we say
Caption: author id equals this and num ratings
Caption: greater than five thousand okay it's a
Caption: little bit different now instead of two
Caption: qualities we have a range query
Caption: i've created this index here
Caption: it's actually wrong i'm going to explain
Caption: a little bit why it's wrong but it's
Caption: also very deceptive and it can catch you
Caption: out quite easily in this case
Caption: this will use the index
Caption: it's in 2.8 milliseconds
Caption: which is pretty reasonable
Caption: and you think okay that's good but
Caption: if i create this in the correct order
Caption: which is
Caption: the columns are now the other way
Caption: it was half the time
Caption: you can imagine if this scales out this
Caption: is only a million rows it's just i
Caption: haven't really fully randomly
Caption: distributed the data that sort of stuff
Caption: this can scale very quickly and becomes
Caption: extremely um it can become an issue that
Caption: you will not spot easily you think
Caption: what's using the index why isn't it
Caption: doing it
Caption: so the way to think about this is you
Caption: want to reduce the amount of the index
Caption: to scan
Caption: so on the left we have the incorrect
Caption: index and what it does is for i said if
Caption: you remember for remember from before it
Caption: will go first it's going to go num
Caption: ratings greater than 5 000.
Caption: it turns out when you do that it scans a
Caption: decent amount of the index
Caption: whereas if i want the correct index
Caption: which is author idea one one one and
Caption: it's quite a selective one as we saw
Caption: before it was only a thousand rows of
Caption: the whole table well
Caption: that's
Caption: not much of the index it has to scan
Caption: so that's going to be much more
Caption: efficient if you think of the cookbook
Caption: if i give you numbers grain 5000 go to
Caption: the book
Caption: okay number eight it's like okay 5 000.
Caption: okay i've got a now i know everything
Caption: after that is greater than 5000. i have
Caption: to scan all of that and figure out where
Caption: the authority is whereas i go author id
Caption: one one one i go i find authority one
Caption: and one one and all my values are there
Caption: it's a very small portion of the table
Caption: we have to scan it's gonna be more
Caption: efficient
Caption: so what to take from that index one of
Caption: qualities then ranges if you do that you
Caption: will avoid this issue biting you
Caption: essentially if you're lucky um that
Caption: query before the wrong one it will just
Caption: do a sequential scan but if you you can
Caption: see that it can still use the index
Caption: sometimes and it won't be as efficient
Caption: okay
Caption: can we do this a bit better hmm
Caption: what do i mean by that let's look at
Caption: this query first of all we're selecting
Caption: everything do we need everything
Caption: i talked to product the product said no
Caption: no no we just want the recipe id please
Caption: that's good enough
Caption: sure
Caption: okay so reminds me it's a two-step
Caption: process right so i need to get all the
Caption: values that fulfill this filter
Caption: then i need to go to the heap or the
Caption: table um the same thing essentially um
Caption: then i got a table to get the rest of
Caption: the row or what i've selected
Caption: what if i could tell
Caption: our query or our index and say hey can
Caption: you also check recipe id and index and
Caption: don't go to the heap and it'll be faster
Caption: so that's called a covering index these
Caption: are included in postgres 11 and onwards
Caption: before you have to do a multi-column
Caption: index which isn't overly great
Caption: admittedly but that's what it kind of
Caption: looks like and we can see here we've
Caption: told hey can you just put risky id with
Caption: my index please and if you only select
Caption: on risky id now
Caption: you can do
Caption: an index scan
Caption: well actually
Caption: index only scan
Caption: and that's the important part to note
Caption: here it's saying index only scan we see
Caption: it took 1.09 seconds it might not seem
Caption: like a huge improvement here um it's
Caption: because it's on my laptop it's not a
Caption: huge amount of data realistically so
Caption: it's all 20 game this will scale very
Caption: quickly
Caption: but one thing you might notice is heap
Caption: fetches so heaps is a table right
Caption: or zero hair but okay why is that why is
Caption: there a heap there so
Caption: essentially what happens is at a very
Caption: this is a very high level explanation
Caption: just for the records a bit more
Caption: complicated than this when it goes to
Caption: the index it gets the value and postgre
Caption: is like hey has this been updated
Caption: recently and if it turns out if it has
Caption: it has to go to the heap and get this
Caption: new value so if you updated that row
Caption: constantly and you run this query it
Caption: will do a bunch of heap fetches which is
Caption: actually slower than an index scan so
Caption: that is something to keep in mind
Caption: okay
Caption: what are
Caption: what is the relation between time and
Caption: rating for recipes for long cooking
Caption: duration so essentially we're trying to
Caption: look at recipes that take longer than a
Caption: day and we want to see the worst rated
Caption: ones for the they have the longest
Caption: duration something like so
Caption: okay cool
Caption: so
Caption: what i mentioned before was
Caption: indexes are ordered
Caption: so if you do a for what they call
Caption: forward scan it's like ordering like
Caption: this backward scans ordering like this
Caption: what does that mean well
Caption: it means that we can avoid sorting
Caption: when we do a query which saves us a bit
Caption: of time
Caption: okay so let's show it's gonna be a bit
Caption: of a wallet that's all right um
Caption: so you can see here we have a sort key
Caption: and now it's so it's got all these
Caption: values and then it's run a sort on it
Caption: and that's taken 60 milliseconds
Caption: but if it was ordered already it
Caption: wouldn't have to do the saw and it'll
Caption: come back faster so first things first
Caption: let's create the index
Caption: which of course i put it wrong because
Caption: this won't quite work um
Caption: now it's down to 37 milliseconds which
Caption: is a i guess what a decent game but not
Caption: a huge game
Caption: and this is where it's a bit deceptive i
Caption: can see a sort method there but i also
Caption: see an index scan
Caption: okay but why i've told it like
Caption: it's ordered why why can't you just give
Caption: it back to me why do you have to do an
Caption: extra step i
Caption: well
Caption: essentially when you create an index
Caption: if i create them
Caption: when i create it without this order here
Caption: it's going to create them descending and
Caption: ascending but
Caption: databases can't scan the leading column
Caption: and one order in the other column in
Caption: another order
Caption: you have to explicitly define this to be
Caption: able to do this
Caption: but it's worth noting this is an
Caption: inflexible query
Caption: now you have to use a query like this
Caption: otherwise at one you won't be using the
Caption: index efficiently
Caption: now we've gone down to 21 milliseconds
Caption: which is a d quite a decent improvement
Caption: that was half of the one before
Caption: which had the index scan but with the
Caption: sorting this one doesn't you can see
Caption: here index condition
Caption: that you can't even see anything about
Caption: um the ordering it just came back
Caption: directly ordered
Caption: and it's a lot faster
Caption: can we do this one better okay
Caption: our index on cooking time
Caption: was the first
Caption: column would we specify when we created
Caption: this index
Caption: okay
Caption: let's visualize as you can see my
Caption: beautiful visualization of cooking time
Caption: it turns out
Caption: um sorry
Caption: we are also filtering on greater than or
Caption: equal to 1440 which is minutes that's a
Caption: day effectively what does that mean well
Caption: if i was to represent the values of
Caption: recipes that take more than a day it'll
Caption: be that little tiny black bar at the
Caption: bottom it turns out most recipes take
Caption: less than a day kind of makes sense
Caption: right usually your recipe takes around
Caption: an hour or less
Caption: okay
Caption: again know your queries i talk to
Caption: product i look at my code and it turns
Caption: out that the only query we ever have to
Caption: do a cooking time is checking if it
Caption: takes more than a day
Caption: okay
Caption: well
Caption: do we need to index everything here what
Caption: if we could just
Caption: index what we need which is recipes that
Caption: take longer than a day
Caption: cool you can see we've essentially
Caption: called what's called a partial index and
Caption: all we had to do was put a filter on it
Caption: after creating the index and that will
Caption: do all its work for us the database
Caption: so when you use these partial indexes
Caption: you have to use the filter here
Caption: otherwise it won't use the index so they
Caption: are kind of inflexible in that regard
Caption: that's where you have to know your
Caption: queries
Caption: and
Caption: this time admittedly maybe the the games
Caption: don't look as great against my it's my
Caption: laptop it's not a huge data set but it's
Caption: still around i think four milliseconds
Caption: gain off the top of my head so it's
Caption: still a decent gain and nothing really
Caption: changes here um it just uses the index
Caption: that's a lot smaller
Caption: so partial index what are they used for
Caption: we use it here to exclude irrelevant
Caption: values
Caption: you can use it to exclude common values
Caption: so good examples aren't null
Caption: if you don't need null values just
Caption: exclude null values on your index
Caption: and another example that can come
Caption: through is we're doing reports
Caption: right what if i had a timestamp column
Caption: and i talked to product and products
Caption: like actually
Caption: it turns out all our reports only need
Caption: data from the last three months that's
Caption: generally how we do these sorts of
Caption: things right
Caption: we could exclude all columns that are
Caption: more than three months old have a time
Caption: center that's older than three months
Caption: which would reduce the size of our index
Caption: and as i said before it must use that
Caption: filter to find in the index or not use
Caption: the index at all
Caption: so
Caption: we need to fix some bugs
Caption: product has came back to us and they've
Caption: kind of been like hey the data is not
Caption: quite matching up we have some queries
Caption: that fill to one category um there's
Caption: this experiment thing that's a tiny tiny
Caption: portion of the table so it's very high
Caption: selectivity okay no worries
Caption: i'll find the one of the queries here
Caption: and it looks something like this
Caption: um i figure out it's the casing the
Caption: casing is not correct okay no worries
Caption: let's fix this easily i put on this
Caption: i deploy it
Caption: it doesn't work okay
Caption: i think while the index is there why is
Caption: it sequential scanning i don't
Caption: understand it it was there right like
Caption: come on what the hell
Caption: okay sure
Caption: what the database sees here is a magic
Caption: black box it doesn't know that that
Caption: function is actually related to the
Caption: experiment at all i can't figure that
Caption: out it doesn't have that information
Caption: so it has to go okay it doesn't fit the
Caption: index i am now just going to do a
Caption: sequential scan sorry
Caption: okay cool
Caption: we can fix this of course we can we
Caption: create an index expression index
Caption: function index whatever we want to call
Caption: it and we put the expression
Caption: inside the index definition and now
Caption: we've done it we deploy it
Caption: works all right okay
Caption: some things to consider here
Caption: very expensive
Caption: what happens every time you write to the
Caption: database that fits this index
Caption: or if you update a row it will compute
Caption: the results of that and store it in the
Caption: index so they're not very efficient
Caption: whatsoever
Caption: in general i have certain indexes uh you
Caption: know increase read speed decrease write
Caption: speed but these are even more heavy so
Caption: do be careful with them i would don't
Caption: use them just because
Caption: and i've used here maybe a bit of a
Caption: contrived example but
Caption: know your queries so
Caption: where this can bite you is rrms orms can
Caption: easily bite you here you might only
Caption: realize it's putting a lower on your on
Caption: your query and you think what the hell
Caption: it's not using index this is ridiculous
Caption: then you look at rms query like okay i
Caption: see why
Caption: um timestamp anything any function
Caption: postgres function will have the same
Caption: issue so always so keep that in mind
Caption: okay
Caption: so we're kind of getting to the end of
Caption: this now and we've talked we've done a
Caption: bunch of work i've shown that kind of
Caption: query planner very high level um
Caption: obviously it's
Caption: one of those things that gets
Caption: complicated extremely quick and i was
Caption: trying to keep this somewhat short
Caption: without going too deep into some things
Caption: so let's think okay
Caption: why isn't your index being used well
Caption: simply
Caption: the database
Caption: can't use the index
Caption: or
Caption: it thinks using index is slower
Caption: what are the reasons so i've covered a
Caption: few reasons the first two i haven't
Caption: covered so table is too small um rule of
Caption: thumb if your table is two pages page is
Caption: eight kilobytes it will not use the
Caption: index the way you think about it is a
Caption: five month cookbook has three pages
Caption: and a one page index what's going to be
Caption: faster you just might as well go through
Caption: a table right i mean through the
Caption: through the book right it's gonna be
Caption: faster than going through the index
Caption: um the operator is another sneaky one so
Caption: this is something that's going to be
Caption: dependent on your database documentation
Caption: will tell you something off the top of
Caption: my head would be
Caption: i like is not supported by b trees and
Caption: postgres so be wary of those sorts of
Caption: things
Caption: and we've talked about these which was
Caption: craig returning too many rows your index
Caption: is not selective enough it will not use
Caption: the index
Caption: you're using your multi-column index
Caption: incorrectly or even inefficiently
Caption: and then we have function indexes being
Caption: used incorrectly
Caption: but
Caption: honestly your database knows best yes
Caption: there are edge cases i haven't covered
Caption: them here because they're quite
Caption: technical and require quite in-depth
Caption: knowledge of everything but
Caption: with my journey with indexes going from
Caption: someone who didn't know anything about
Caption: them at all to now i kind of realized
Caption: database is honestly kind of magic it's
Caption: an absolute miracle that these things
Caption: work as well as they do without any
Caption: issues it's we stand on the shoulders of
Caption: giants when it comes to these things so
Caption: do keep that in mind
Caption: okay
Caption: so i kind of said some of these things
Caption: i've gone surface level um
Caption: gets a bit more complicated which might
Caption: sound a bit of a cop out i've included
Caption: some stuff here if you're like i want to
Caption: learn more please give me more
Caption: so first thing will be multiversion
Caption: concurrency control that's how we update
Caption: the same table times how to keep things
Caption: updated
Caption: um vacuuming is how is kind of related
Caption: to that
Caption: and then the last one which is how does
Caption: your database calculate the statistics
Caption: and how does it use the statistics and
Caption: query planning and you can add to that
Caption: understanding the query planner even
Caption: deeper
Caption: that was a like yeah ridiculously high
Caption: level overview of the query planner it
Caption: gets much much much more complicated
Caption: extremely quick
Caption: so we'll look um postgres documentation
Caption: is actually incredible um it's very
Caption: in-depth maybe not the most prettiest
Caption: thing to read but it does the job
Caption: there's a really good site called user
Caption: index look um like the guy that is a
Caption: database wizard as far as i'm concerning
Caption: explains absolutely everything in depth
Caption: there's article and everything and it's
Caption: really worth giving it a read
Caption: and
Caption: yeah so what what what's the takeaways
Caption: from this
Caption: know your queries
Caption: again what are your most important
Caption: queries most executed queries what are
Caption: your expensive queries with that
Caption: knowledge you should be able to judge
Caption: what index you should create
Caption: what are the traders of you creating the
Caption: index on the choices that you made from
Caption: creating that index and from then it's
Caption: going to be a bit easier
Caption: that's all for today
Caption: thank you i hope you enjoyed my talk
Caption: thanks boris and thanks everyone for
Caption: coming i'm happy to take away oh cool
Caption: okay
Caption: yeah cool questions
Caption: uh for the creating the index and using
Caption: the concurrently keyword is that only
Caption: for when you're creating an index after
Caption: you've created the table
Caption: or yes so you'll need to create index
Caption: after table so
Caption: um you can't do a migration that creates
Caption: table and creates index it won't work
Caption: you have to do it afterwards
Caption: thanks boris um
Caption: you said there was a
Caption: slight
Caption: hit if you have a if you create an index
Caption: there's a increased
Caption: right time in order to build that index
Caption: do you know
Caption: sort of what numbers around that we're
Caption: talking milliseconds seconds minutes um
Caption: it's a very good question
Caption: yeah um i
Caption: maybe i forgot to put the disclaimer um
Caption: a lot of this stuff
Caption: it's hard to quantify because it just
Caption: depends on a lot of variables what what
Caption: what's the machine your database is
Caption: running on how much data does it has the
Caption: distribution of the data there's lots of
Caption: factors that come into this um
Caption: so i can't just give you a percentage
Caption: because it just depends way too much but
Caption: it will make your right slower and the
Caption: more indexes you have on a table it's
Caption: going to get worse
Caption: rule of thumb i'll kind of say if you
Caption: see more than five indexes on a table
Caption: it's a bit smelly that doesn't look
Caption: right
Caption: thanks to talk really enjoyed it i'm
Caption: just going to ask if you have any really
Caption: real life examples of how you've used
Caption: queries or maybe some of the foot guns
Caption: you've encountered um
Caption: yeah i do we have a few yeah um one
Caption: example we have a two i can't give you
Caption: the numbers off the top of my head
Caption: unfortunately but we have a few well we
Caption: have one that just would not run out all
Caption: the queries would not return um
Caption: completely stopped our processors so i
Caption: think there's a two billion row table
Caption: and we check the index on it and it runs
Caption: i think in roughly a second now
Caption: and that was it was a simple index too
Caption: but yeah there's been a few um things
Caption: that we've done
Caption: thank you so much um
Caption: i have a question with it's slightly
Caption: related to index so um it's
Caption: to do with the postgres specific random
Caption: page cost and sequential page yep i
Caption: think it was random page course and the
Caption: other was a sequential yeah um have you
Caption: ever
Caption: um play with that yep um i kind of
Caption: avoided it but uh not deliberately um i
Caption: talked a bit with someone who's a
Caption: database god in our company and gave me
Caption: a bunch of advice so
Caption: random page cost is well the cost
Caption: essentially using index because it's
Caption: random rather than you know going
Caption: through the table you're kind of like
Caption: randomly going to the table um
Caption: these days it used to be a bigger issue
Caption: back in the day with the old hard drives
Caption: we have ssds now
Caption: the recommendations from the
Caption: aurora guys people at amazon is you
Caption: reduce so sorry defaults
Caption: sequential page cost is one and random
Caption: is four so the aurora the people aurora
Caption: actually i recommend or a database for
Caption: aws there you actually recommend
Caption: dropping your random page across to 1.5
Caption: or two i believe off the top of my head
Caption: um because we don't have hard drives
Caption: that seek on a needle we have ssds which
Caption: are ridiculously faster essentially
Caption: do you have any suggestions on how to
Caption: safely like test indexes in production
Caption: or like a a system that needs to stay up
Caption: fingers crossed
Caption: no that's yes that's a very hard one and
Caption: unfortunately it's just one other
Caption: so okay
Caption: there are some ways actually i can give
Caption: you if you have the same amount of data
Caption: and dev as in prod the distribution
Caption: needs to be the same too you'll actually
Caption: get very similar results not timing wise
Caption: there are other things you could do
Caption: which get a bit complicated um buffers
Caption: is something to look at which is the i o
Caption: work done but even then
Caption: it gets even trickier because it's some
Caption: things like if i'm running this craze
Caption: again and again and again you'll see the
Caption: times change varying because casein the
Caption: database cajon actually has cases in
Caption: operating system um so you can still use
Caption: it as a judgment core of or be
Caption: performing or not what you could do if
Caption: you really want you create the um i
Caption: don't know if your company allows this
Caption: but you can create your index you can
Caption: log on to the production database create
Caption: it manually test your query manually if
Caption: you can bear the load and see if it'll
Caption: actually be efficient that's one way
Caption: i've seen or doing if you're really not
Caption: sure but um that comes down to
Caption: just if you can deploy it to a small
Caption: subset of customers and just see hey
Caption: what's the impact here can we and can we
Caption: roll back quickly
Caption: that sort of stuff
Caption: uh i just had a quick question about the
Caption: um specific data types that a database
Caption: column could have um would indexing um
Caption: affect that at any point or should i say
Caption: with the type effect indexing so whether
Caption: it be a date and time would it be a json
Caption: object yeah yeah um do not create
Caption: indexes on json
Caption: uh
Caption: it's okay um i know we've tried to do it
Caption: and it's not very efficient there are
Caption: other indexes you can use but it's a bit
Caption: hard to do from my understanding yes the
Caption: the size of the the value gets very
Caption: important this is at a very large scale
Caption: when you're talking like billions of
Caption: billions of rows that's when if you
Caption: index on like an int which is i can't
Caption: remember what the sizes are postgres
Caption: versus
Caption: the other ones i can't remember they're
Caption: a bit smaller you can see huge increases
Caption: in times depending on that and that's we
Caption: have to be careful covering indexes like
Caption: you don't want to put a json b column of
Caption: covering index because that's going to
Caption: make your index gigantic what's the
Caption: point awesome thanks
Caption: outgoing anyone else
Caption: cool
Caption: thank you everyone
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so the next talk starts at 12 20.
Caption: i think it's detected you
Caption: ah what's going on what's going on
Caption: just to this morning
Caption: let's try that
Caption: hang on hang on hang on hey we're
Caption: cooking right
Caption: you're right to try the audio yeah yeah
Caption: for
Caption: get used to audio um okay um
Caption: oh what's going on there
Caption: what do you mean check audio normally i
Caption: just press that it says mute
Caption: on mute
Caption: or did you want to try and play it or
Caption: just try and find it
Caption: do you know hang on let's try it without
Caption: it first
Caption: i'm saying it's muted which is really
Caption: weird all right let's get out of here
Caption: hello
Caption: you probably know max better than me
Caption: i've only had this about a month
Caption: in the middle yeah i had it um when i
Caption: was downstairs i muted it
Caption: but i normally just press the button on
Caption: the top and if it goes
Caption: oh that one there yeah yeah
Caption: because you're plugged into the hdmi
Caption: it's tracker all right yeah yeah yeah
Caption: yeah yeah normally
Caption: yep
Caption: cool and that's it so it'll just
Caption: all right let's switch slides
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: there's no we have to that audio will
Caption: come out through the stream though i
Caption: think when we're testing it
Caption: i of course need no introduction yeah
Caption: abby
Caption: i'm sorry you guys might take a photo of
Caption: us
Caption: do you want to take a photo of me
Caption: i am
Caption: i just want to put up on this
Caption: because i want to go on one of the
Caption: slides when i get there
Caption: oh that one
Caption: cool
Caption: um
Caption: yeah if you can do it as a like a
Caption: portrait that'd be awesome
Caption: cool all right let's get started and
Caption: i'll have to be a little bit faster i
Caption: think um
Caption: so my name's david martin and i'm
Caption: talking about the use of deep fakes
Caption: in social media and my journey of um in
Caption: that space the last sort of nine to 12
Caption: months
Caption: so
Caption: onward so first off thanks to the triple
Caption: d conference people making it possible
Caption: it's my second year it's an awesome
Caption: experience please apply to talk there's
Caption: great subjects and i'm always interested
Caption: to read more and see more so i'm sure
Caption: everyone else is too so yeah please
Caption: apply if you get the chance and big
Caption: thanks to the guys looking after the
Caption: coffee cart i'll be there later on
Caption: cool
Caption: i of course need no introduction
Caption: but i have the pleasure of introducing
Caption: david martin he is chief technology
Caption: officer at grafa a fintech startup here
Caption: in perth
Caption: before joining graffa he was the
Caption: technical lead for the covet 19 response
Caption: for the western australian department of
Caption: health
Caption: he also teaches machine learning and
Caption: data analytics at the university of
Caption: western australia
Caption: between you and me he's been naughty
Caption: this year and is not getting anything
Caption: from me
Caption: enjoy the talk i hope you come away
Caption: inspired
Caption: stay
Caption: safe thank you santa claus
Caption: so how many of you know what a deep fake
Caption: is or i think you know what a deep fake
Caption: is yeah heard the term yeah cool
Caption: hopefully i'll challenge that um
Caption: understanding later today oh the next
Caption: few minutes
Caption: so how do they get here so last year i
Caption: know those of you who saw me talk or see
Caption: me babble on linkedin um i was playing
Caption: with machine learning operations or
Caption: mlops last year i was looking for
Caption: ways of automating um looking for
Caption: trading strategies on the asx so i'm a
Caption: big fintech fan
Caption: and love finance and luckily i'm
Caption: programmers so i've got to mix the two
Caption: and look at trading models and one of
Caption: the things i learned from that was
Caption: trying to capture sentiment how does how
Caption: do people feel about a company even if a
Caption: company puts out positive information is
Caption: the stock price going to go up because
Caption: people trust the company so what's the
Caption: sentiment towards it and trying to
Caption: capture that in a data sense is actually
Caption: incredibly difficult i can't really put
Caption: a survey out so how do you how do you
Caption: capture it
Caption: and further to that is um
Caption: i was like inventing new things and
Caption: launching new um ideas and so in the
Caption: finance space i was i started something
Caption: called blue harvest but i need to market
Caption: it i know nothing about marketing i'm a
Caption: programmer i like to have friends who
Caption: are marketers you've got to explain and
Caption: go you know look at this look at that so
Caption: i actually got to learn but i'm time
Caption: poor so i need to automate it how do i
Caption: market automate my marketing right it's
Caption: a dream
Caption: next thing is in the startup world i've
Caption: got no money right so free or cheap
Caption: if i can do that too even better
Caption: and the third component is video content
Caption: it's got to be video content if you look
Caption: at tik tok it's exploding you know
Caption: people writing text stories posts
Caption: whatever it doesn't seem to be as
Caption: popular anymore as video content so i
Caption: need to automate it it needs to be free
Caption: i need to make videos
Caption: so pretty tall order but that's that's
Caption: the challenge i set myself because the
Caption: other day if i'm launching something i
Caption: need i need marketing otherwise you go
Caption: nowhere right business fails
Caption: no matter how good it is
Caption: so today i want to discuss is um just a
Caption: quick one through social media concepts
Caption: and numbers just some terms um that
Caption: you've probably heard in social media
Caption: just explain a bit more and then some
Caption: numbers around so you get an
Caption: appreciation of
Caption: how that works in the social media space
Caption: and what they mean
Caption: next thing is data baseline so let's
Caption: capture some data from let's call it my
Caption: visibility in social media or of this um
Caption: this blue harvest thing i'd written and
Caption: how i mean i measure that as a starting
Caption: point and do i succeed do i get more
Caption: free marketing
Caption: and the next piece is deep fakes so
Caption: that's the idea of using that video
Caption: content you know synthetic media is
Caption: another term and i'll get into that
Caption: later
Caption: but deep fakes how do we use these
Caption: videos how can we automate video
Caption: production
Caption: and the net result did it work did it
Caption: just tank and did i waste my money my
Caption: time
Caption: so let's get going
Caption: so first off social media people know
Caption: what impressions are yeah someone looked
Caption: at your cat video that's an impression
Caption: right picture of your kid that's an
Caption: impression
Caption: engagement
Caption: yeah that's when someone press like
Caption: repost retweet um i can't think of
Caption: another nerd but you know those things
Caption: they've interacted with your with your
Caption: social media content whatever that may
Caption: be
Caption: followers yeah you hear influencers bang
Caption: on about followers so and donald trump
Caption: will tell you with 90 million of them or
Caption: used to have
Caption: when you put out a piece of content
Caption: immediately all your followers get to
Caption: see it that's the first group of people
Caption: that see it then after you after they
Caption: like retweet whatever then out it goes
Caption: so really followers help you project
Caption: your post so really increasing followers
Caption: and some people pay for them is very
Caption: important so that's another level to
Caption: consider
Caption: and the last thing i want to um explain
Caption: there is organic versus paid so organic
Caption: is you taking a picture of your cat and
Caption: sticking it on wherever it was instagram
Caption: whereas paid some people pay content
Caption: writers advertising um the company i
Caption: work for actually does that sort of
Caption: stuff make social media posts for
Caption: companies um so there's a whole market
Caption: in that space and can be quite expensive
Caption: even simple text posts with photos take
Caption: money and time
Caption: so engagement rates which you heard me
Caption: just discussed previously so just keep
Caption: the math simple twitter's at one percent
Caption: that's considered a good engagement rate
Caption: oh sorry my slides are now out of it
Caption: that's a good engagement rate so what
Caption: that means is if you had 100 people see
Caption: your your cat tweet and one person hit
Caption: like or retweet or whatever that's good
Caption: right that's considered a good number i
Caption: know sounds crappy but it's good
Caption: and you can see along there there's
Caption: linkedin at 6 and so on so forth so just
Caption: to keep the maths easy one person 100 is
Caption: considered success on twitter
Caption: so next piece is how much are people
Caption: spending on marketing
Caption: so twitter 1.4 billion dollars in
Caption: advertising
Caption: profit last calendar year us
Caption: facebook at 50 billion and number number
Caption: one is google 200 billion dollars in
Caption: advertising so it's a fair whack of
Caption: money and if i can avoid giving them any
Caption: more i um certainly would try
Caption: so video content so what are some stats
Caption: around video content what what makes us
Caption: so popular
Caption: so the first thing is 78 of people watch
Caption: online videos every week and that's in
Caption: some form whether it's you know autoplay
Caption: on twitter or tick tock whatever um it's
Caption: it's incredibly popular
Caption: the next two thing uh next stat is 72
Caption: percent of customers rather learn this
Caption: way so let's think of my dad building
Caption: his lawnmower he just bought the other
Caption: week we found a video online on how to
Caption: build it because reading a manual sucks
Caption: whereas if someone shows you how to do
Caption: it you can always learn faster and
Caption: acquire the skills or knowledge faster
Caption: the next one is message retention more
Caption: people remember the message you put in a
Caption: video than a piece of text
Caption: and finally more businesses are doing it
Caption: it's going up every year and probably
Caption: it's a it's a self-fulfilling thing you
Caption: see tick tock being populous people
Caption: trying to get on tick tock causes more
Caption: videos more businesses get on there and
Caption: on it goes so really if you're going to
Caption: advertise your business having a video
Caption: even casual videos you've just shown on
Caption: your iphone is a really good idea it
Caption: really does help
Caption: and the one that blows me away is the
Caption: cost a professional one minute of
Caption: finished video is between one and ten
Caption: thousand dollars and i got that from a
Caption: friend of mine in the us that's the cost
Caption: who's got that kind of money around for
Caption: one minute you want to put lots of
Caption: videos out every month because you want
Caption: to you know stay relevant so an insane
Caption: cost and no startup can keep up with
Caption: that so anything you can do to get it
Caption: free and cheap um the
Caption: better so for me in my journey what i
Caption: did was i had to get some data you know
Caption: get the data is is one of my favorite
Caption: saying so what i'm showing you here this
Caption: is a tweet from one of my twitter
Caption: accounts it's completely automated
Caption: now just to explain market sensitive
Caption: announcements are announcements that
Caption: companies put out on the stock exchange
Caption: hence the asx that are sensitive that
Caption: would move the share price and all my
Caption: little piece of code does is every time
Caption: one of those announcements are published
Caption: by the asx on behalf of company i tweet
Caption: it you can see it there so it gives you
Caption: the name of the company gives the name
Caption: know the title of the announcement
Caption: timestamp and a couple of hashtags so
Caption: i'm going to hashtags what i do want to
Caption: call out is the uh m s
Caption: now what that is in the trading space is
Caption: those of you who are um what they call
Caption: finn tweets or uh finance people who are
Caption: on twitter
Caption: these dollar signs are the same as a
Caption: hashtag but in the finance world we use
Caption: that to i'm going to look at bhp or cb
Caption: you can do yourselves you got a twitter
Caption: account and what you'll see is all the
Caption: tweets that's how we tag companies and
Caption: it's done all over the world
Caption: what occurred to me was i could now look
Caption: at um what's called a popularity or um
Caption: yeah popularity of
Caption: a particular company in this case mns i
Caption: know what the hell they do but i can
Caption: type that into twitter and i'll see all
Caption: the tweets about them
Caption: so what occurred to me was i've been
Caption: doing this about 12 18 months i could
Caption: download all this data and see how
Caption: frequently is mns discussed how
Caption: frequently is it engaged with because
Caption: what it does is when i'm trying to make
Caption: video content which is expensive is i
Caption: can now target my video content towards
Caption: the more popular asx companies
Caption: so i use the twitter api download all
Caption: the stats from my twitter account let's
Caption: cover how long it took i'm sorry so just
Caption: to point out as well i apologize you can
Caption: see on the bottom the 5 the 1 and the 26
Caption: it's a bit faded out that's the
Caption: engagement so you've got 26 likes a
Caption: retweet and five comments whatever they
Caption: are
Caption: so that's the stats that's engaging with
Caption: downloading um for every tweet
Caption: so this is from sql server it's a little
Caption: bit rough i apologize
Caption: you can see on the top i've got the a6
Caption: codes down the left and then i've got
Caption: engage and percentage and then you can
Caption: see impressions and those you know other
Caption: concepts i talked about so you can see
Caption: uh because i wrote the tweets i can get
Caption: the a6 code up so i can tell you what's
Caption: popular so tcl don't know what they do
Caption: eight percent engagement
Caption: we're off one tweet so what that says to
Caption: me is you've got engaged shareholders
Caption: i'm not gonna get into that whole side
Caption: of things there's a whole other
Caption: experiment um
Caption: but the point is you can see there's a
Caption: high level of engagement with certain
Caption: stocks and i've just grabbed the top
Caption: dozen there just to show you um based on
Caption: engage and percentage of eight percent
Caption: which is you know eight times better
Caption: than what they say the good rate is so
Caption: fantastic
Caption: but also we can look at impressions if
Caption: you look at m s one we just showed the
Caption: tweet for 4 700
Caption: uh impressions views 4700 people saw all
Caption: the three tweets
Caption: but a low engagement rate so it really
Caption: depends on marketing do you want people
Caption: engaging their content or do you want
Caption: people seeing you so that's the
Caption: difference between brand awareness and
Caption: you're trying to get them to buy your
Caption: stuff
Caption: so if we flip that on this header there
Caption: you go so tcl is it eight percent and
Caption: mns is one i just showed
Caption: so what if we flip it what if we just
Caption: look at impressions look at the very top
Caption: asn six and a half thousand impressions
Caption: for the same time period so straight
Caption: away using this list and i think i think
Caption: ms came at number three here
Caption: oh apologies my slides are out of sync
Caption: because they're on my laptop
Caption: so
Caption: so what i'll show you here is you can
Caption: see those high numbers of impressions
Caption: and the top um
Caption: 20 down to agy there which is one of the
Caption: stocks i decided to focus on them
Caption: so what i decided was is there's plenty
Caption: of news stories written about these
Caption: stocks if you're on twitter or linkedin
Caption: or whatever is i'm going to write video
Caption: content about those news stories so
Caption: basically getting a free write off
Caption: someone else's content
Caption: so what i did was i thought well i'll
Caption: focus on the top 20 because then i can
Caption: focus you know my spend and my effort on
Caption: those and that's the only tweets i send
Caption: out so you really want to keep the um
Caption: you really want to keep the volume down
Caption: so based on that sorry let's get going
Caption: through
Caption: um i started looking at video content
Caption: and now we'll talk about deep fakes
Caption: hi i'm santa claus this is the real me
Caption: hi i'm santa clauses digital twin the
Caption: difference between a deep fake and a
Caption: digital twin is that a digital twin is
Caption: made with consent of the person
Caption: whereas a deep fake is done without
Caption: consent
Caption: so thank you santa claus for that
Caption: explanation and that's the bit i wanted
Caption: to bring up so deep fakes i think is the
Caption: pejorative or the you know the negative
Caption: term digital twins are done with consent
Caption: that's very important in all this this
Caption: guy's an actor my kids aren't in the
Caption: room this guy's an actor okay so
Caption: we have to be respectful towards the
Caption: actors and this they are paid okay
Caption: they're paid to use their likeness so
Caption: there's very strict rules or ethics
Caption: around what you do it can't be political
Caption: can't be religious you know no
Caption: harassment no bullying this is very
Caption: important this and a lot of the
Caption: platforms i assume all the platforms
Caption: police that there's a lot of content
Caption: moderation intentionally because what
Caption: you're doing is you're getting santa
Caption: claus or somebody else
Caption: to say something and they wouldn't even
Caption: know it's been done
Caption: so it's very important all this and
Caption: that's where the difference between a
Caption: deep fake and digital twin so there's i
Caption: think the most commonly ripped off guys
Caption: um tom cruise he's an actor plenty of
Caption: footage
Caption: so um
Caption: yeah most common stuff but that's the
Caption: big difference here is we use digital
Caption: twins which most people know is deep
Caption: fakes but that's that's a very important
Caption: difference there
Caption: so
Caption: what platforms are there's plenty of
Caption: them and they're changing all the time
Caption: now the cool one i want to call out here
Caption: is one dollar per finish minute
Caption: that's a big difference from that one
Caption: grand you'd have to hand over
Caption: now obviously it's a bot so it's not
Caption: perfect right that you know that
Caption: technology is still evolving but i've
Caption: given you three examples there our one
Caption: that's an israeli company there's plenty
Caption: more and that's where synthetic media
Caption: comes and if you google that and have a
Caption: look around just there's plenty of stuff
Caption: ideally if you're gonna automate you
Caption: want an api um clearly otherwise you're
Caption: doing manual ones all day long
Caption: um i will share the slides at the end if
Caption: you guys wanna have a look so um you get
Caption: all the reference points what i've
Caption: chucked on the right there very quickly
Caption: is a sample of what i've been doing
Caption: yeah so at the tops the video just run
Caption: that in a second and you can see the
Caption: tweet attached to it and you can see
Caption: importantly this company is cyano
Caption: another company i put the dollar sign
Caption: sya that means anyone who's following
Caption: that stock on twitter will see my video
Caption: yeah
Caption: um justin from motley fool
Caption: why is the say ownership price lifting
Caption: on monday
Caption: published the 5th of september
Caption: visit blue harvest digital to get the
Caption: latest news and market information
Caption: fairly simple straightforward easy to do
Caption: did that through an api so as i'm
Caption: standing here with you as i love to tell
Caption: people that things probably making
Caption: videos so it is possible and these kinds
Caption: of things do at a very low price
Caption: so
Caption: that was all very interesting david but
Caption: what were the results
Caption: was it worth it
Caption: stamped into the whole 20 minute talk
Caption: with the video but i changed my mind
Caption: so i put a few in so this is another one
Caption: called sofia the other guy's called paul
Caption: they're all actors so you like to refer
Caption: my name it's kind of cool
Caption: um anyway some stats so did it work was
Caption: i wasting my time i always believe
Caption: learning something new is not a waste of
Caption: time but nonetheless
Caption: so tweet only text 0.63 well below the
Caption: one percent that they say is good video
Caption: tweets three point nine nine and that's
Caption: just those top 20 companies now the
Caption: thing is that constantly changes as
Caption: engagement changes for those stocks the
Caption: top 20 is dynamic it'll pick whatever's
Caption: in the list so i couldn't tell you what
Caption: list is right now well i screenshot the
Caption: other day but nonetheless it changes all
Caption: the time based on traffic which is great
Caption: so
Caption: that is 6.5 times better and i'm
Caption: producing about 60 minutes of video a
Caption: month so about 60 bucks give or take i'm
Caption: completely automated
Caption: so that's that was the um
Caption: the big one for me there and i didn't
Caption: know that until i did the chart so i was
Caption: quite impressed
Caption: the next one very quickly
Caption: is linkedin so linkedin i publish
Caption: content too and i'll just show you the
Caption: competitors these are financial news
Caption: companies in australia publishing asx
Caption: content you can see me sorry it's called
Caption: border herald this time but that's me
Caption: there i've just named everyone else to
Caption: protect the innocent but you can see the
Caption: followers you know 1100 compared to 16
Caption: 000 at the top so massive difference
Caption: but the cool thing is with automated
Caption: content i'm a number two on engagement
Caption: so i am beating um that and that top
Caption: company 150 million asx company with
Caption: three full-time staff
Caption: so it is you know you can get you can
Caption: get in the fight with marketing with
Caption: this sort of stuff and that's the last
Caption: six months
Caption: and finally um
Caption: some people saw the weird i do on
Caption: the internet and they um said come be a
Caption: cto at a fintech so it's been absolutely
Caption: awesome so i hung up my time at health
Caption: after 20 odd years and came to work for
Caption: them and i've been there about six
Caption: months
Caption: um yeah that's that that's me in the
Caption: back row somewhere but that's that's the
Caption: talk
Caption: sorry for the av malfunction um
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: it's four minutes left for rovers so if
Caption: you want to mug me outside and ask
Caption: questions you're welcome to or twitter
Caption: or something
Caption: that's right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: very good
Caption: i'll introduce
Caption: so just while he's typing the password
Caption: in
Caption: off screen
Caption: i'll introduce you to damien he runs the
Caption: developer advocacy at github and loves
Caption: all things devops formerly a cloud
Caption: advocate at microsoft for four years and
Caption: prior to that a debit octopus deploy and
Caption: and microsoft mvp damian has 20 plus
Caption: year background in software development
Caption: and consulting in a broad range of
Caption: industries
Caption: he regularly speaks at conferences just
Caption: like this
Caption: uh user groups and other events around
Caption: the world sorry that was mean
Caption: this is not
Caption: this is not his fault just just like
Caption: this actually
Caption: so let's give damian a big long welcome
Caption: as he sets himself up
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: this is going well um
Caption: i'm going to skip all my slides because
Caption: that's a boring bit anyway um and i'm
Caption: just going to go straight to demo so
Caption: my name is damian brady i work at github
Caption: i lead our developer advocacy team
Caption: i came from microsoft i've talked about
Caption: devops for years um
Caption: this time i'm going to be talking about
Caption: devops
Caption: in terms of doing it all on code on
Caption: sorry on github
Caption: right so we're going to be going from
Caption: planning and tracking all the way
Caption: through to the inner loop like actually
Caption: writing code
Caption: in the cloud on code spaces
Caption: and then
Caption: actions to deploy
Caption: like with a ci cd pipeline all the way
Caption: through to the end
Caption: right
Caption: now
Caption: i started about 15 minutes late so let's
Caption: see how quickly we can do this if i skip
Caption: over stuff and you're like i really want
Caption: to know more about that
Caption: we have all of this demo stuff at the
Caption: github booth as well so come and have a
Caption: look the difference in the github booth
Caption: though is that everything's running off
Caption: a raspberry pi so i'm doing
Caption: multi-container
Caption: development debugging and stuff but my
Caption: dev machines this raspberry pi hanging
Caption: from a carabiner next to the tv
Caption: we'll see some of that in a sec not the
Caption: raspberry pi but the code spaces right
Caption: so devops you've all seen that kind of
Caption: uh
Caption: sideways eight like the infinity symbol
Caption: that we talk about with devops where we
Caption: do plan you know build
Caption: deploy and then learn from that
Caption: the idea with devops being that you can
Caption: get through that whole like
Caption: infinity symbol as quickly as possible
Caption: so get stuff out to production as
Caption: quickly as possible so you can learn
Caption: from it and work out what needs to be
Caption: done next right
Caption: what i'm going to focus on today is
Caption: everything from the plan bit all the way
Caption: through to production right we're not
Caption: really going to talk so much about the
Caption: learning from it
Caption: github doesn't have a product for
Caption: for you know looking at metrics of
Caption: things that are going on in production
Caption: we do have awesome kind of tooling
Caption: around discussions with your communities
Caption: and of course there's github issues that
Caption: can be open so
Caption: the community can contribute as well or
Caption: your customers can contribute as well to
Caption: what you're doing but we're not going to
Caption: really cover that that part so much
Caption: beyond just
Caption: issues all right i'm already talking too
Caption: much let's go and have a look you can
Caption: see a little bit about some of the
Caption: security stuff that's built in here as
Caption: well um
Caption: dependebot has told me that my code has
Caption: security vulnerabilities
Caption: which is deliberate i promise
Caption: i'm just going to ignore them at the
Caption: moment which is also deliberate
Caption: oh this is going to be fun your scroll
Caption: thing's the reverse of what i usually
Caption: use
Caption: yeah
Caption: i'm playing in hard mode alright
Caption: who is familiar with github issues
Caption: yep okay cool if you're not github
Caption: issues is kind of the way that we track
Caption: a piece of work so
Caption: issues uh the word issue as we use it is
Caption: a thing that we need to care about
Caption: ultimately it's fine i'll work it out um
Caption: okay oh yeah um it's it's a thing we
Caption: need to care about right it's not
Caption: a bug it's not a synonym for a bug
Caption: although you can absolutely track your
Caption: bugs using github issues we use issues
Caption: internally for everything at github so
Caption: we
Caption: in our devrel organization we have a
Caption: repository that has very little code in
Caption: it but we use issues to track all of the
Caption: work that everybody is doing
Caption: the whole way through and you'll see
Caption: some of the planning and tracking tools
Caption: and why it's it's valuable to do that
Caption: regardless of whether they're actual
Caption: pieces of code that you need to change
Caption: or not
Caption: so the github issues um ui when you go
Caption: to the issues tab in github
Caption: you'll just get this list of all of the
Caption: issues that are in there you know
Caption: categorized by open and closed you can
Caption: do some great searching and filtering
Caption: and stuff like that apply labels all
Caption: that kind of thing um
Caption: and so the the experience with actually
Caption: creating issues and using issues is
Caption: pretty good too so if we create an issue
Caption: um
Caption: you know you can give it a title uh
Caption: what's the title fix that laptop output
Caption: which is a good one
Caption: um
Caption: and then you can you know put a whole
Caption: lot of detail about um
Caption: stuff
Caption: what's the screenshot in windows windows
Caption: shift s
Caption: yeah
Caption: i'm a pro
Caption: um
Caption: you can even do things like paste
Caption: images wrong keys
Caption: you can even like copy and paste images
Caption: so i just took a screenshot
Caption: and then
Caption: the preview can see that screenshot that
Caption: i just took
Caption: so you can copy paste
Caption: images you can do rich markdown
Caption: formatting all that kind of stuff
Caption: there's some really good features around
Caption: task lists too so you can set a list of
Caption: you know things you need to do
Caption: a second thing
Caption: and then
Caption: when you save or submit that issue just
Caption: get rid of that last one
Caption: you can see that there's a task list
Caption: attached to this issue as well
Caption: and we can see that there are two tasks
Caption: for that issue that need to be done and
Caption: maybe i want to
Caption: say i've done the first thing
Caption: but maybe the second thing needs a
Caption: little bit more work and so i can
Caption: just need to refresh
Caption: wrong buttons
Caption: f5
Caption: no that's all right
Caption: see this is why i have a desktop pc at
Caption: home and a macbook so i know both of
Caption: them
Caption: anyway so this second one maybe i want
Caption: to actually convert that to an issue
Caption: because it needs some more expansion
Caption: there's some more details when i do that
Caption: it'll create an issue from that second
Caption: thing and if i drill into that issue
Caption: we can see that that is tracked in one
Caption: of the previous issues so we have this
Caption: kind of hierarchy the hierarchy stuff in
Caption: github issues is still kind of being
Caption: built out it will be a lot richer in the
Caption: future um right now we we kind of do
Caption: have this hierarchy between
Caption: and you can go down as deep as you want
Caption: if i did a task list in this and
Caption: converted them to issues you can see
Caption: that it's tracked in those ones as well
Caption: that stuff will start surfacing a bit
Caption: more
Caption: soon
Caption: so we've got our issues uh we can do
Caption: real really rich markdown we can even do
Caption: like mathematical formulas and we use um
Caption: tooling to
Caption: do flow charts and stuff like that you
Caption: can put in there in markdown it's this
Caption: github flavored markdown that we have
Caption: which is a little bit richer
Caption: but this probably isn't the best way to
Caption: like manage all of your issues you might
Caption: have thousands of issues
Caption: you can't really run a sprint just by
Caption: well you can
Caption: run a sprint by just applying a label to
Caption: that issue for sprint one and then just
Caption: filtering to those labels it's not the
Caption: best way to work
Caption: so we've got issues sorry we've got
Caption: github projects now github projects is
Caption: new
Caption: if you have used github projects in the
Caption: past you might have used the the legacy
Caption: projects which we've now deprecated
Caption: there is a really nice migration path
Caption: from the old projects to the new
Caption: projects um
Caption: mitch just did a video on that really
Caption: recently i don't know how where we've
Caption: have we published it on youtube
Caption: on instagram today there we go
Caption: um
Caption: and so i'm going to create a new project
Caption: uh
Caption: i'm going to go to the organization to
Caption: create a project
Caption: uh where are we new project
Caption: and we'll call it dddd perth now i can
Caption: choose one of the templates for these
Caption: projects or i can just go from scratch
Caption: i'm just going to go from scratch just
Caption: to show you how powerful this is
Caption: and i'm going to add the issues from my
Caption: repository so to do that
Caption: by the way we're looking at the table
Caption: view at the moment
Caption: to add an issue i choose my repository
Caption: uh
Caption: it's high queues for code spaces
Caption: and then i'm just gonna
Caption: choose yeah that one
Caption: so now i have that issue in there
Caption: oh this thing's hurting me
Caption: um
Caption: and i can add
Caption: left click
Caption: we've also made this quite like keyboard
Caption: friendly so i'm just kind of hitting
Caption: enter and it's taking the top one each
Caption: time just to fill them out
Caption: and we've now got this
Caption: list of
Caption: you know issues that we're working with
Caption: we've got our columns we've got
Caption: assignees we've got the status of those
Caption: issues as well now status is something
Caption: that belongs to the board
Caption: so by default you get to do in progress
Caption: and done but i can change those statuses
Caption: i can have whatever statuses i want but
Caption: i can also have custom fields in here
Caption: so i can say i want to see the labels
Caption: that's great that's pretty useful but i
Caption: want a new field for
Caption: an estimate
Caption: and then that field type is a number
Caption: and now we have this estimate column as
Caption: well
Caption: so i'm just going to go and put some
Caption: random numbers in that estimate column
Caption: if i can work things
Caption: i'm putting random numbers in because
Caption: this is like a real life demo where
Caption: estimates are totally random anyway
Caption: and then i can obviously do things like
Caption: filter and say i only want to see the
Caption: estimates that are greater than five oh
Caption: keyboard shortcuts
Caption: the opposite so ctrl k on windows by the
Caption: way no
Caption: not windows k um and i can filter by
Caption: you know um
Caption: here we go estimate and just say it has
Caption: to be greater than five and it'll filter
Caption: based on those so we can do that we can
Caption: group by
Caption: the statuses grouped by the labels uh
Caption: let's group by actually we need another
Caption: field here for
Caption: sprint and this is actually a iteration
Caption: type
Caption: and it starts today iterations go for
Caption: two weeks
Caption: so in the background it's created some
Caption: iterations for me based on every two
Caption: weeks
Caption: and i can assign these to these sprints
Caption: as we go as well so
Caption: yeah let's do that
Caption: and then we'll
Caption: group by these
Caption: so now we've got all of our sprint one
Caption: sprint two sprint three and then the
Caption: ones that haven't been
Caption: haven't been done yet
Caption: so we got this like nice little table
Caption: view
Caption: the other thing we might want to do
Caption: though is have like a sprint board right
Caption: so let's create a new view
Caption: and this view is going to be
Caption: a board view
Caption: and so now we have our
Caption: board for all the ones with no status so
Caption: by default it's kind of giving me the
Caption: status so to do doing done none of these
Caption: have a status so i obviously want some
Caption: of them over here
Caption: but actually this is my sprint board so
Caption: i'm going to
Caption: filter by
Caption: sprint
Caption: and then just say
Caption: the current sprint
Caption: so
Caption: you can say yeah this is the current
Caption: sprint or the previous sprint or the
Caption: next sprint you can even say current
Caption: plus two or previous minus one or
Caption: something like that which is pretty
Caption: handy um and then you can work with
Caption: these these sprint boards as well you
Caption: can change what's on the cards
Caption: i mean this is a
Caption: demo that i could spend hours and hours
Caption: on
Caption: if i could work the mouse
Caption: one thing to note as well is that these
Caption: projects are
Caption: at the organization level
Caption: so we understand that you might have
Caption: issues across a number of different
Caption: repos
Caption: um for a project especially if you have
Caption: a microservices situation where you have
Caption: a different repo for your different
Caption: services but you want this roll-up view
Caption: of all of the things that are going on
Caption: at the moment
Caption: so at the org level you have a project
Caption: and you pull in the issues that you care
Caption: about for that project across the
Caption: different repositories or maybe pull in
Caption: the pull requests because you care about
Caption: them as well so issues and pull requests
Caption: can appear here
Caption: you can also have the same issue in
Caption: multiple projects and those projects can
Caption: have different custom fields so here
Caption: i've got a bunch of work that's going on
Caption: maybe my managers want a different view
Caption: of all of the epics
Caption: in my organization
Caption: across multiple projects and they also
Caption: have some fields they want to track like
Caption: maybe they just want a current status of
Caption: red green and um
Caption: yellow or something like that
Caption: that extra field belongs to that project
Caption: and the issue can set you know that
Caption: value on the project so you can have
Caption: different views of the same information
Caption: the great thing about this though is you
Caption: can absolutely customize this for
Caption: however you want
Caption: you don't need to
Caption: you know you're not stuck in the way
Caption: that github thinks you should run a
Caption: project
Caption: you can do it any way you want
Caption: the one thing i didn't show you on this
Caption: which i love
Caption: is that you can also put in draft issues
Caption: so i can add one here to say
Caption: i don't know get a new laptop there's a
Caption: theme for these issues by the way um and
Caption: this is a draft issue because it doesn't
Caption: belong to a repository yet it just
Caption: belongs to this project
Caption: we have teams
Caption: in github who use basically nothing but
Caption: draft issues they
Caption: do everything as draft issues and it's
Caption: only when they actually need to do the
Caption: work that they will
Caption: convert to an issue
Caption: and then it will ask you what repository
Caption: you want that issue in because it has to
Caption: belong to a repository at that stage
Caption: so look i could i could go on and on
Caption: about all of this sort of stuff um
Caption: before i move on to kind of moving on
Caption: from the planning any questions about
Caption: stuff that i haven't shown you on here
Caption: anyone want to give me a laptop
Caption: and staying down okay
Caption: so look this is also free for everybody
Caption: we don't charge anything for github
Caption: projects so your own repositories you
Caption: can do it um or your own organizations
Caption: your own accounts you can have projects
Caption: as well anything you anything you like
Caption: there's no extra money for this there's
Caption: some other features that i didn't show
Caption: you as well to do with like workflows um
Caption: so when
Caption: a an issue sorry when an issue gets
Caption: dragged into the done column then market
Caption: is closed in the repo and things like
Caption: that i'm sorry other way around
Caption: a bunch of things like that there's more
Caption: coming to workflows as well there's also
Caption: insights that is i don't know if it's
Caption: public preview yet i think it's in the
Caption: public beta um insight so you can do
Caption: your burn down charts or burn up
Caption: cumulative flow diagrams or the
Caption: management manager stuff as well
Caption: somebody from github in the back is
Caption: looking at me like i don't know if
Caption: that's public
Caption: yeah so org level for the oh yeah okay
Caption: there we go so the burn up charts and
Caption: stuff are at the
Caption: enterprise right or all global burn up
Caption: chats yeah
Caption: cool
Caption: awesome all right let's go back to this
Caption: code and we're gonna do some of this
Caption: work all right so
Caption: uh i don't know if anybody here had the
Caption: same experience as me with my first dev
Caption: job is it took
Caption: literally about a month before i could
Caption: actually write code on the code base
Caption: because they had to find me a computer
Caption: and then they had to set that computer
Caption: up with the standard operating
Caption: environment and then the project i was
Caption: on had these other dependencies that i
Caption: needed in there as well
Caption: so you know time to actually writing the
Caption: first code or making the first commit
Caption: was long right
Caption: which is a problem especially if you are
Caption: on multiple projects i don't know if
Caption: anybody's skipped from one project to
Caption: another and there's this period of
Caption: how do i get all this stuff working
Caption: they're using different versions of the
Caption: dependencies all that kind of stuff
Caption: it's also bad for
Caption: open source and for contributing to
Caption: other projects inner source is a problem
Caption: as well so i know when i worked at
Caption: microsoft
Caption: everyone at microsoft every engineer at
Caption: microsoft has access to almost every
Caption: repository every code base
Caption: and you're encouraged if you find
Caption: something that you need in somebody
Caption: else's code base to submit a pull
Caption: request like to to actually go and
Caption: change it look at their code see how it
Caption: works which is great except i can't
Caption: debug that because they've got this huge
Caption: list of dependencies
Caption: i can't get that working it's not worth
Caption: my time so i just don't do it
Caption: enter code spaces so code spaces is a
Caption: dev environment in the cloud that's
Caption: targeted at a specific repository so you
Caption: basically have the definition of what's
Caption: required to write code for a project
Caption: defined alongside the code for that
Caption: project
Caption: before
Caption: before code space as well if you just
Caption: want to make a small change you don't
Caption: need to do any debugging or anything
Caption: like that just in case anybody hasn't
Caption: seen this before
Caption: this is in every repository if you hit
Caption: the dot button presuming it's the same
Caption: on a different laptop
Caption: um the full stop button dot button
Caption: period whatever you want to call it
Caption: on any github repo even if it's not
Caption: yours
Caption: it'll open the web editor
Caption: which is basically visual studio code
Caption: running in your browser so there's no
Caption: compute on the back end in this case
Caption: it's just running inside your browser
Caption: and
Caption: you can make changes to the code you can
Caption: not debug
Caption: but you can submit
Caption: a code change you could submit a pull
Caption: request you can do all of that kind of
Caption: stuff
Caption: um
Caption: yeah so you can make small changes
Caption: i actually use this constantly like if i
Caption: need to make a small change to a readme
Caption: or something like that i'll just hit dot
Caption: open it up in here
Caption: um this is also really really good for
Caption: code reviews so if somebody submits a
Caption: pull request and you go to the pull
Caption: request page and hit the dot you're
Caption: brought to visual studio code to the web
Caption: editor or web-based editor
Caption: in the context of looking at that pool
Caption: request
Caption: so you can see the changes you can see
Caption: what was committed
Caption: the files that are different and you can
Caption: leave comments and say this looks good
Caption: if you have permissions you can even
Caption: merge those pull requests
Caption: in the context of a visual studio code
Caption: instance so you can see the library you
Caption: can see all the files you can see
Caption: everything like that
Caption: but like i said what you can't do here
Caption: unfortunately
Caption: is
Caption: debug
Caption: especially if you don't know the
Caption: shortcut keys
Caption: so there's no terminal because there's
Caption: no compute in the background
Caption: i can't do any run and debug stuff
Caption: because there's no compute in the
Caption: background
Caption: and obviously in the real world you need
Caption: to do that stuff so code spaces is
Caption: basically the same as this
Caption: except
Caption: it has compute it's a cloud-based dev
Caption: environment
Caption: now because we're short on time normally
Caption: i'd create a new one to show you how how
Caption: quickly this works but
Caption: if you go to the code button here and
Caption: then go to code spaces
Caption: uh
Caption: and i've got one here which is not clean
Caption: that's great
Caption: oh you know what i'm just going to
Caption: create a new code space
Caption: so you can see how fast it is
Caption: um so what it is doing is spinning up a
Caption: container in the cloud that's running on
Caption: a machine
Caption: um that has
Caption: uh whatever resources i need to give it
Caption: there are a number of sizes for these
Caption: code spaces as well so you can do
Caption: you know two core machines up to i think
Caption: it's 32 core if you ask us nicely
Caption: um
Caption: i think by default you can do anything
Caption: up to 32
Caption: uh core machines i believe
Caption: um and they get charged basically per
Caption: minute like so they get charged based on
Caption: usage
Caption: um
Caption: the good thing as well is if you leave
Caption: them
Caption: like you you log out and you don't do
Caption: anything you don't stop them they'll
Caption: stop themselves after a period of time i
Caption: think by default it's 20 or 30 minutes
Caption: it'll stop itself we did an internal
Caption: survey because fun story github github
Caption: so github.com which is a mono repo which
Caption: is about 11 gig of code
Caption: we do github.com entirely on code spaces
Caption: so we use this internally for our own
Caption: gigantic repo
Caption: using some features like pre-builds so
Caption: we can oh that's good
Caption: so using some features like pre-builds
Caption: we can get the speed of like starting a
Caption: new code space up
Caption: sorry down to really really small
Caption: small numbers
Caption: so
Caption: if this works um i'll show you that in a
Caption: sec but
Caption: for github.com 11 gig code base about 23
Caption: gig on disk if you do a deep um clone
Caption: takes about
Caption: i think it's about 10 seconds 10 12
Caption: seconds to go from clicking the button
Caption: to being able to debug the code with
Caption: multiple containers running different
Caption: services
Caption: in a debugging environment
Caption: and you can commit code and do that work
Caption: straight away
Caption: it's super powerful and it also means if
Caption: somebody new joins the team they just
Caption: create a new code space and they can
Caption: write code immediately
Caption: if you start working on a different
Caption: project
Caption: and they have code spaces set up there
Caption: you can go to that other project starter
Caption: code space and now you have this brand
Caption: new dev machine that's targeted
Caption: specifically at um at that repository
Caption: and at that code base
Caption: so here we go
Caption: we are in
Caption: and this is my little application
Caption: uh let's see if i can run it in debug
Caption: it's a node app
Caption: so i'll choose node
Caption: and remember this is all running just um
Caption: through my browser i don't have this
Caption: code base on this machine on this laptop
Caption: at all
Caption: not just
Caption: not just for the obvious reasons that
Caption: it's not my laptop
Caption: this actually makes the demo kind of
Caption: cool right
Caption: um
Caption: you know i don't have the code on here
Caption: because it's not my machine
Caption: um but i'm still able to
Caption: you know do the work to write the code
Caption: so this is what the application looks
Caption: like
Caption: if i go back into my codespace again in
Caption: the browser
Caption: and i find
Caption: a file let's find
Caption: index.js
Caption: get rid of that and then i'll put a
Caption: break point on that render
Caption: and refresh
Caption: and in my other browser tab i've hit
Caption: this breakpoint and you get all of the
Caption: nice stuff that you would normally get
Caption: debugging in a vs code instance
Caption: on somebody else's computer or on a
Caption: raspberry pi
Caption: wherever you are right
Caption: so pretty cool pretty cool stuff
Caption: i was going to do a tiny little co-pilot
Caption: demo but instead you should go and go to
Caption: misha's talk
Caption: at 3 15 i think where she's gonna do
Caption: co-pilot entirely um but i was going to
Caption: like randomize those haikus but i don't
Caption: remember how to do it so i would do
Caption: something like
Caption: yeah i'd need to install co-pilots i'm
Caption: not going to do it um just ask co-pilot
Caption: to tell me how to randomize in node
Caption: because i don't know
Caption: right so that's code spaces it's super
Caption: powerful
Caption: you can also connect remotely from a
Caption: visual studio code instance on your
Caption: local machine if you want to
Caption: you can stop them start them disconnect
Caption: and have multiple running at the same
Caption: time
Caption: so if you are doing some work for one
Caption: particular a branch of your code you can
Caption: have a code space open for that and
Caption: another one for the main one and so on
Caption: um
Caption: and as i said they'll stop themselves
Caption: if you're not using them we did a little
Caption: survey internally for github github to
Caption: find out how often people
Caption: how often people actually stopped the
Caption: code spaces themselves or how often they
Caption: just like
Caption: turned their computer off and waited for
Caption: it to stop itself
Caption: and it was uh approximately there might
Caption: be a little bit of counting error
Caption: approximately a hundred percent of
Caption: people didn't turn it off they just let
Caption: it expire so
Caption: yeah
Caption: uh yeah so one yeah that's a very good
Caption: point i overheard there which is that's
Caption: because they work at github and they
Caption: don't pay for these which is true
Caption: um i did a little back of the envelope
Caption: calculation and if you're running i
Caption: think it's a 16 core machine or
Caption: something like that and you're working 8
Caption: hours a day
Caption: 50 weeks a year or 48 weeks a year or
Caption: something like that it's about
Caption: equivalent to
Caption: buying a new laptop every two years or
Caption: something like that but remember you've
Caption: got these code spaces that you can have
Caption: in all of these different environments
Caption: and they just don't charge you for usage
Caption: when they're shut down so you could have
Caption: 30 projects that you're working on with
Caption: 30 different code spaces that you can
Caption: start working on immediately
Caption: from any laptop you have it doesn't need
Caption: to be new
Caption: you should definitely have the newest
Caption: best laptop though that's a good idea
Caption: yeah
Caption: so
Caption: i'm running low on time as well so we're
Caption: going to move very quickly to the next
Caption: bit so that's kind of our inner loop
Caption: that's a dev environment that means that
Caption: i can write my code really quickly i can
Caption: get started on new projects
Caption: and i don't have to worry so much about
Caption: the hardware or the dependencies running
Caption: on my local machine super powerful but
Caption: then when i have made the change how do
Caption: i get that into production and this is
Caption: one of the probably better known
Caption: features i guess of github which is
Caption: github actions who uses github actions
Caption: okay probably about half the room who's
Caption: heard of github actions like who's aware
Caption: of it the same people
Caption: well now the rest of you have heard
Caption: about it so you can move into the next
Caption: column of using it
Caption: rather than actually run one of these
Caption: i'm going to show you one i've run
Caption: before
Caption: so
Caption: the great thing about github actions is
Caption: the definition of how to build your
Caption: application and how to deploy your
Caption: application is defined in a yaml file
Caption: that sits alongside your code
Caption: so when somebody clones or forks your
Caption: repository they know not just what the
Caption: code looks like but what the build
Caption: situation is and what the deployment
Caption: situation is they can see all of that
Caption: if you've got a specific code space
Caption: definition set up so you can customize
Caption: those code spaces in huge ways they also
Caption: know what the dev machine needs to look
Caption: like as well
Caption: whether you're using code spaces or dev
Caption: containers just locally
Caption: you know what it you know everything
Caption: about that project you have the code you
Caption: have the definition of how you're going
Caption: to like write code against it like what
Caption: dependencies you need and then you have
Caption: the definition of how you build it and
Caption: how you deploy it and it's just all
Caption: there in your repository
Caption: this is kind of a more mature looking
Caption: pipeline we've got three stages here i'm
Caption: going to try and zoom in a bit
Caption: uh i don't think this zooms great here
Caption: there we go we've got three stages here
Caption: we've got a build stage which does my
Caption: compilation
Caption: and we have a deployment stage which
Caption: just deploys to
Caption: azure in this case and then we have a
Caption: production stage now the thing that i've
Caption: set up with production is it knows the
Caption: production environment needs approvals
Caption: before it goes to production
Caption: so by saying in that definition i'm
Caption: deploying to production you get this
Caption: protection where it has to pass a bunch
Caption: of rules before it's allowed to go into
Caption: production in this case that rule is i
Caption: need to approve that before it goes into
Caption: production
Caption: you can put other rules in there like
Caption: you can only deploy to this environment
Caption: from these branches of your repository
Caption: so maybe you're doing a branching
Caption: strategy where it's a trunk based
Caption: development and people do feature
Caption: branches but then they merge back into
Caption: your main branch before it goes out to
Caption: production you want to make sure nobody
Caption: deploys to production from a feature
Caption: branch right so you can put that
Caption: protection on it as well and nobody can
Caption: actually approve that to go to
Caption: production
Caption: so this went to the staging site it went
Caption: to the production site we've got a track
Caption: of the deployments like the reviews
Caption: sorry who did a review
Caption: and then we've even got the artifacts
Caption: that were produced as well so part of
Caption: the build was packaging everything up
Caption: and then uploading it so the subsequent
Caption: jobs could pull that down and do the
Caption: work
Caption: i actually deployed them as well
Caption: the way these actually physically run
Caption: is on these ones are on github hosted
Caption: runners so these are
Caption: agents that basically spin up when you
Caption: when there's a job to do
Caption: it'll download the code or do whatever
Caption: you want it to do
Caption: and then when it's finished it'll tear
Caption: itself down entirely so they're on
Caption: demand kind of hosted runners you can
Caption: also self-host runners
Caption: if you want you can run the running the
Caption: runner executable on pretty much any
Caption: machine i've run them on raspberry pi's
Caption: too so you can actually build your
Caption: application on a raspberry pi if you
Caption: really want to don't do that um or you
Caption: can do the github hosted ones really new
Caption: to github hosted runners as well is the
Caption: larger sizes of github hosted runners so
Caption: for for a very long time you didn't get
Caption: to choose how big those runners were the
Caption: only way to choose
Caption: how much ram and all that kind of stuff
Caption: was to do your self-hosted ones now for
Caption: github team i believe and github
Caption: enterprise cloud you can
Caption: set up uh
Caption: larger hosted runners to say i want you
Caption: know one with
Caption: 32 cores and gpus and all sorts of stuff
Caption: so
Caption: uh
Caption: yeah long running builds or ones that
Caption: are a bit slow you can do use hosted
Caption: runners for those
Caption: now
Caption: there is a lot that i didn't cover in
Caption: this for several reasons um
Caption: if you want to see any of this stuff in
Caption: a little bit more
Caption: detail
Caption: we've got demos at the booth we've got
Caption: an awesome demo that was actually
Caption: written by aaron powell who is probably
Caption: in that room
Caption: which
Caption: has a code space with multiple
Caption: containers that get run and debug at the
Caption: same time with azure cosmos db emulators
Caption: running in them
Caption: and the actual device that i've the
Caption: keyboard and mouse is connected to is
Caption: this little raspberry pi but it's
Caption: running 32 cores in the background and
Caption: 32 gig of ram in code spaces and things
Caption: like that
Caption: we use github issues
Caption: for our price draw as well if you
Caption: haven't signed up for that so if you go
Caption: to a particular github issue you can
Caption: leave a comment and then we use github
Caption: actions to pull the names from the names
Caption: of the people who commented on that
Caption: issue
Caption: put them in a file and do that as part
Caption: of the deployment to github pages that i
Caption: also didn't mention which is a way you
Caption: can host your own static websites
Caption: in github so the whole thing like kind
Caption: of fits together until you get this
Caption: end-to-end scenario
Caption: so planning and tracking with github
Caption: issues and github projects
Caption: code spaces for that in a loop of
Caption: actually doing development really
Caption: quickly and really efficiently
Caption: especially for new people to the team
Caption: and then github actions which is an
Caption: automation platform that kind of lets
Caption: you do your ci cd
Caption: or kind of any other automation as well
Caption: but
Caption: fantastic for ci cd and we've got most
Caption: of the way around
Caption: there until we get back to issues again
Caption: which is the learning from what's in
Caption: production
Caption: as i said tons of stuff i didn't see i
Caption: didn't tell you about um
Caption: come over to the booth and ask some of
Caption: us for some demos of the stuff that's
Caption: there and otherwise thanks so much for
Caption: your time
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: and thanks mish for the laptop
Caption: thanks damian that was really cool um so
Caption: it's off to lunch now everybody uh
Caption: so there's lunchtime sessions commencing
Caption: at 2 35 in the theatre and both river
Caption: rooms and you can't take food into them
Caption: so if you do want to duck into those get
Caption: your food in quickly and then the next
Caption: breakout sessions will start again at 3
Caption: 15.
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott held someone's oh
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now auth zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a
Caption: customer cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together
Caption: now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stopped
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the very completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also got a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here to boost your experience and boost
Caption: your personality everything in a compact
Caption: pack that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: do
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: what we're doing is we're talking to
Caption: people all over the world because we're
Caption: stuck in our poses
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made sure dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: done
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: being puree
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the very completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top 1 is the best of the best and for me
Caption: it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: dream come poses i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh
Caption: the app is almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: nice
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this office nerd's nerding what we're
Caption: doing is we're talking to people all
Caption: over the world because we're stuck in
Caption: our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that when they see when they
Caption: see the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accents so
Caption: the beret completely makes sense as for
Caption: the being no matter the client no matter
Caption: where i was working it always was a pink
Caption: background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn it does not
Caption: reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also got a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-down
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top 1 is the best of the best and for me
Caption: it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're just stuck in our
Caption: houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero up what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: god
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: this is office nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're just stuck in our
Caption: houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my goal sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very prominent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top down
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better i think that's really
Caption: important and i think it's going to be a
Caption: driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: and i was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services mlq digital
Caption: helps clients to fully understand their
Caption: it needs adopt the right solution and
Caption: provide ongoing support to maximize
Caption: their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puppies
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a
Caption: disaster we need something to keep our
Caption: users data private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: night
Caption: [Music]
Caption: good afternoon everybody thanks for
Caption: coming for the last session for today
Caption: um so we have aiden sobe here he is a
Caption: cloud native data engineer at kzn who's
Caption: on a mission to fight jargon one acronym
Caption: at a time
Caption: welcome aiden fantastic
Caption: everyone hear me alright
Caption: cool hello everyone and welcome to data
Caption: lakes
Caption: and other bodies of water that killed
Caption: big data
Caption: before we begin i'd like to acknowledge
Caption: the traditional custodians of the land
Caption: the wardrobe people of the noongar
Caption: nation
Caption: i'd also like to say a big thank you to
Caption: all of the sponsors today as well as the
Caption: ddd uh volunteers they've put a massive
Caption: effort in and it's made today flow very
Caption: smoothly so thank you
Caption: now
Caption: today i'm going to take you through the
Caption: death of big data and then dive into the
Caption: technology that has pushed it out of the
Caption: spotlight spoiler alert it's data lakes
Caption: then we're going to dive into what data
Caption: lakes actually do
Caption: and following that i'll explain a few
Caption: other water analogies in the data area
Caption: so my name is aiden as you've just been
Caption: told and i'm a senior developer with kz
Caption: kzn is a cloud consultancy that
Caption: specializes in serverless technology and
Caption: data engineering we have and continue to
Caption: build data lakes for a range of clients
Caption: and
Caption: let's get started
Caption: so
Caption: to kick off this story of how big data
Caption: went from buzzword number one to a thing
Caption: of the past i'm going to rewind to the
Caption: beginning of time that was the mid 1980s
Caption: in a simpler time
Caption: we had data
Caption: data was stored in data warehouses
Caption: we used sql to extract value from that
Caption: data in the form of reporting
Caption: and that was it
Caption: very simple
Caption: they like it so
Caption: now
Caption: as we move forward to roughly 2011 we
Caption: get into the age of big data let's
Caption: define big data before we move forward
Caption: big data refers to data sets that are
Caption: too large or complex to deal with using
Caption: traditional methods traditional methods
Caption: largely being data warehouses
Caption: now what caused the rise of big data
Caption: lots of things but a major one with
Caption: social media companies realizing how
Caption: much money they can make from pushing us
Caption: personalized ads
Caption: other areas of technology started to
Caption: pick up like iot
Caption: if you look at things like cars 20 years
Caption: ago they were purely mechanical devices
Caption: if you're lucky they had electric
Caption: windows but now we have companies like
Caption: tesla or waymo where your cars are
Caption: streaming vast volumes of data up
Caption: to lose my sound
Caption: okay we're streaming vast volumes of
Caption: data up into the cloud from almost every
Caption: appliance across the globe
Caption: to give some idea of scale in 2010
Caption: roughly 1.2 trillion gigabytes of data
Caption: was generated by the human race
Caption: in 2021 that number was 18 trillion
Caption: gigabytes
Caption: we are on an exponential exponential
Caption: curve of data growth and the scale of
Caption: our data sets is more important now than
Caption: it ever has been
Caption: the problem
Caption: there was a few
Caption: including structure which we'll talk
Caption: about later but the key point i'm going
Caption: to focus on here is the pure volume
Caption: traditional methods like data warehouses
Caption: just could not scale or ingest data fast
Caption: enough to keep up with the demand
Caption: and hence
Caption: big data
Caption: volumes of information too large to be
Caption: dealt with using traditional methods
Caption: so what happened to this huge problem
Caption: that we saw on every news channel and
Caption: every magazine cover
Caption: to give you an anticlimactic answer
Caption: the problem got solved
Caption: daleks provide a cheap and readily
Caption: available means of storing and ingesting
Caption: almost unlimited quantities of data
Caption: that's it
Caption: data engineers can sleep at night and
Caption: everyone lived happily ever after
Caption: except it wasn't quite that simple
Caption: datalake solved a lot of the problems of
Caption: big data a bit in a classic tech fashion
Caption: replace those problems with newer
Caption: challenges
Caption: but before we dig into that i'm hoping
Caption: at this stage you have one very simple
Caption: question bouncing around inside your
Caption: head
Caption: what is a data lake and how did it solve
Caption: these problems
Caption: i'm glad you asked because someone had
Caption: to to start understanding data lakes
Caption: we're going to need to look at data
Caption: warehouses that we talked about earlier
Caption: now data warehouses were the core of
Caption: business intelligence for the last 30
Caption: something years
Caption: for those that are new a data warehouse
Caption: is a data management system designed to
Caption: enable business intelligence activities
Caption: that basically means we have data
Caption: and we want to get value out of it
Caption: we can break this down a little bit by
Caption: looking at our key components we have a
Caption: data warehouse which has a database or a
Caption: variety of databases within it we have
Caption: etls that's the extraction
Caption: transformation and loading of data
Caption: between different sources
Caption: and then the system is set up in a way
Caption: that allows integrations with external
Caption: services whether it's an erp system like
Caption: sap or oracle or a crm like salesforce
Caption: through to analytics like power bi or
Caption: tableau
Caption: now the important thing to understand
Caption: about data warehouses is that they store
Caption: data
Caption: in databases
Caption: and databases only accept structured
Caption: data
Caption: hence a data warehouse can only store
Caption: structured data
Caption: but what is structured data
Caption: now data can be structured or
Caption: unstructured and this is one of the keys
Caption: to understanding data lakes and the role
Caption: they play in superseding data warehouses
Caption: in the race to accommodate fast
Caption: quantities of data
Caption: let's start by looking at one of the
Caption: most common types of unstructured data
Caption: a csv
Caption: now maybe the csv came from a script
Caption: reading an api maybe it was an export
Caption: from some third-party system
Caption: as you can see
Caption: we have data
Caption: but we know very little information
Caption: about this data
Caption: what are the data types
Caption: is that an integer or a decimal is it
Caption: signed or unsigned
Caption: is this field allowed to be null or
Caption: should it have a default value when it's
Caption: empty is there a primary key or is there
Caption: a composite number of columns that
Caption: should uniquely identify a row
Caption: all of these questions are vitally
Caption: important for us to actually utilize our
Caption: data but they cannot be answered without
Caption: structure
Caption: this file for example could not be
Caption: loaded into a data warehouse unless we
Caption: knew what the structure was
Caption: so what does structure look like
Caption: i'm going to throw another very common
Caption: term around that everyone has heard but
Caption: a lot of people don't really understand
Caption: and that's metadata
Caption: metadata is information about data
Caption: in our csv example metadata could be an
Caption: information file that provides answers
Caption: to our questions data types unique
Caption: constraints null handling
Caption: now there's another common type of
Caption: metadata involved with data lakes and
Caption: that's governance data when we have
Caption: hundreds or thousands of source systems
Caption: feeding into one big data platform it's
Caption: very important for us to know where that
Caption: data came from who's responsible for it
Caption: how often it's refreshed what the
Caption: quality is there's lots of questions but
Caption: for the sake of this speech we're going
Caption: to focus on the first type
Caption: which is the actual structure of our
Caption: data we can see you know this string has
Caption: a maximum length of 255. we can see that
Caption: this field is nullable this is the
Caption: structure to our data
Caption: so
Caption: what's very important to understand
Caption: is that when we have unstructured data
Caption: and the metadata that corresponds to it
Caption: we can combine those two things to
Caption: produce structured data
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: to solidify our metadata learnings
Caption: metadata is information about data this
Caption: information allows us to specifically
Caption: describe the format and structure of our
Caption: data and this allows us to treat the
Caption: data as structured which unlocks new
Caption: ways of analyzing storing and
Caption: classifying the information
Caption: now this is great but it feels like i'm
Caption: off on a tangent so why do we care about
Caption: structure
Caption: we care because of the definition of a
Caption: data lake a centralized store for
Caption: structured and unstructured data at any
Caption: scale
Caption: the first big difference between a data
Caption: lake and a data warehouse is that data
Caption: lakes accept any kind of data whereas
Caption: warehouses only accept structure
Caption: a good analogy is there's two toddlers
Caption: and a playground one of them is the
Caption: picky kid that only eats foods that are
Caption: a certain color and then you have the
Caption: one in the sandbox eating handfuls of
Caption: sand
Caption: it's not bothering anyone but he doesn't
Caption: care he'll take anything in and that's
Caption: what a dad lake is
Caption: now in real life business systems the
Caption: majority of our inputs are usually
Caption: unstructured
Caption: exports from apis data dumps from
Caption: external systems and manually entered
Caption: information is normally unstructured
Caption: but as businesses want to make
Caption: data-driven decisions we need all of
Caption: this information to be stored in a
Caption: structured way
Caption: this is so we can accurately query it
Caption: for business intelligence and analysis
Caption: and that's what a data lake does
Caption: it provides a single body for storing
Caption: structured and unstructured data as well
Caption: as defining automated processes for
Caption: adding structure to that data
Caption: let's dig into it a little bit more
Caption: everyone loves aws architecture diagrams
Caption: so i threw one in
Caption: so
Caption: let's walk through it step by step
Caption: first on the left we have a range of
Caption: data sources some of these are
Caption: unstructured some are structured
Caption: again that's the key difference between
Caption: a data warehouse and a data lake all
Caption: inputs are accepted
Caption: next you'll notice there are two zones
Caption: an unstructured zone and a structured
Caption: zone
Caption: it's very important we have both of
Caption: these so that we can accept unstructured
Caption: or structured data in from outside
Caption: systems
Caption: it's also very important because as we
Caption: move
Caption: data through a data lake
Caption: generally we have a range of zones and
Caption: as we move through those zones our
Caption: structure sorry our data becomes more
Caption: structured and has a higher quality to
Caption: it that's why we've got the structured
Caption: zone to the right of the unstructured
Caption: zone
Caption: you can see between the two zones we
Caption: have a glue job
Caption: this is aws speak for an etl that's the
Caption: extract transformer load we talked about
Caption: earlier
Caption: now this glue job takes unstructured
Caption: data
Caption: and it applies metadata
Caption: to add structure to it and move it into
Caption: the structured zone
Caption: it's worth noting that you can't just
Caption: throw a random csv in and expect the
Caption: metadata to somehow be known for every
Caption: source that you ingest from you need to
Caption: have the metadata for that data set
Caption: once that data is sitting safe and
Caption: structured it can be brought into
Caption: into the structured zone
Caption: what i have here is a data warehouse and
Caption: an s3 bucket but what's important to
Caption: understand is that a data lake does not
Caption: prescribe the tooling that we use okay
Caption: you can have a data lake without a data
Caption: warehouse or you can have one with one
Caption: what matters is that you have a store
Caption: for that structured data
Caption: you can also see that we have a variety
Caption: of business
Caption: integrations like sage maker that
Caption: applies artificial intelligence or
Caption: predictive analysis over the data power
Caption: bi for visualization and coding
Caption: again these are not prescribed tools
Caption: these are commonly used ones but what
Caption: really matters in a data lake is that
Caption: you allow for the integration of
Caption: external services that provide this kind
Caption: of value
Caption: now data lakes also give us the
Caption: opportunity to tap into a buzzword that
Caption: executives go crazy for and that's real
Caption: time it gives me shivers just saying it
Caption: what is real time
Caption: basically it means there's a very small
Caption: turnaround between an event occurring
Caption: and that data being presented to the end
Caption: user that's it
Caption: any modern data lake will provide
Caption: tooling that allows you to stream high
Caption: volumes of data in real time
Caption: and the aws solution i'm showing you
Caption: here is a kinesis stream
Caption: these streams go into a data store and
Caption: then we have an external tool like
Caption: grafana that reads it at very small time
Caption: intervals
Caption: again just one component inside the
Caption: ecosystem of a data lake
Caption: now
Caption: this is why data lake solved the big
Caption: data problem for everyday companies
Caption: the cost efficiency and scalability of
Caption: the modern cloud allows us to store
Caption: enormous volumes of unstructured and
Caption: structured data without any real
Caption: specialist input
Caption: we don't need big data phds to set up
Caption: hadoop clusters and you rarely even need
Caption: database administrators because all of
Caption: your instances are running in managed
Caption: services
Caption: that might be controversial
Caption: the problem of scaling is gone
Caption: so big data sets aren't scary anymore
Caption: i'm sure other big scary problems didn't
Caption: just take their place
Caption: except they did
Caption: common side effects of data lake usage
Caption: include but are not limited to data
Caption: governance issues performance con
Caption: performance complaints and massive scope
Caption: group
Caption: when you have thousands of data sets
Caption: coming from hundreds of sources being
Caption: transformed left right and center it
Caption: gets very messy understanding who's
Caption: responsible for what data sets and what
Caption: they get used for if at all
Caption: next the 16 petabyte redshift cluster is
Caption: going to be slower to query than a 500
Caption: megabyte local ms access file
Caption: that's the reality but end users don't
Caption: care about your excuses
Caption: and with scale come slow
Caption: another big one is that now that we have
Caption: all this amazing and readily accessible
Caption: data we need to do more with it than
Caption: just run reports
Caption: data lakes represent a big step forward
Caption: in enabling machine learning as well as
Caption: predictive analysis and automated
Caption: decision making
Caption: because solving a problem isn't enough
Caption: once we can do something we have to
Caption: figure how to get the most value out of
Caption: it
Caption: and suddenly our problem of there's too
Caption: much data to store becomes a problem of
Caption: how do we get the most out of all this
Caption: data that we have
Caption: anyway this slide is not here for
Caption: solutions only pessimism and now that we
Caption: understand what a data lake is and how
Caption: it killed big data we can move on to the
Caption: next item
Caption: which is other bodies of water
Caption: now it's worth noting while i'm here
Caption: that this speech to some extent
Caption: is an opinion piece
Caption: there is no
Caption: standard body that defines exactly what
Caption: a data lake or a data point or a data
Caption: bottle is
Caption: they're just kind of terms that people
Caption: have come up with and every company uses
Caption: them in a slightly different way
Caption: but
Caption: for some reason a lot of next generation
Caption: data infrastructure follows water naming
Caption: so let's start with the biggest and the
Caption: most difficult to understand the data
Caption: swamp
Caption: simply put
Caption: a data swamp is a bad data lake
Caption: data swamps come around when we have
Caption: poor data quality or poor data
Caption: governance
Caption: they're bad don't do them any questions
Caption: no good
Caption: okay
Caption: next we're moving down the scale a data
Caption: puddle is a single purpose data lake
Caption: used by a specialist team for a very
Caption: specific reason
Caption: it is often used as companies migrate
Caption: into the cloud and want to dip their
Caption: toes and test things out for one
Caption: specific use case before they try to
Caption: scale up and move their whole business
Caption: over
Caption: you can see this in my extravagant
Caption: diagram where a collection of happy
Caption: synergistic teams make use of a data
Caption: lake whereas one sad lonely solitary
Caption: team makes use of their sad lonely data
Caption: puddle
Caption: we don't see this too wild on the often
Caption: and if i'm honest i'd never heard of
Caption: this term before i started researching
Caption: for this speech but these are generally
Caption: used as a proof of concept or by a road
Caption: team that is sick of their company's
Caption: data architecture
Caption: that said
Caption: well that really resonated
Caption: all right
Caption: that said they provide an important role
Caption: in our next body of water
Caption: the data pond
Caption: this can be described as a collection of
Caption: small isolated data systems
Caption: and you might have a dozen different
Caption: teams who each have their own data
Caption: puddle on shared infrastructure the key
Caption: difference here between a data pond and
Caption: a data lake is minimal shared governance
Caption: or data the accounting team uses their
Caption: accounting data that they ingested the
Caption: engineering team uses their engineering
Caption: data that they ingested but there's not
Caption: a lot of crossover it's not one huge big
Caption: lake of shared data that everyone taps
Caption: into for their own purposes
Caption: this again is often seen as a stepping
Caption: stone to data lakes but for smaller
Caption: companies it may be suitable on its own
Caption: so
Caption: in summary who killed big data
Caption: it was the data lake
Caption: in the cloud with the scalability
Caption: in a more general sense cloud technology
Caption: has provided everyday businesses with
Caption: the ability to scale their data
Caption: infrastructure
Caption: much more easily than before and as a
Caption: result the traditional methods that
Caption: couldn't handle big data have become a
Caption: thing of the past
Caption: we've learnt the data lakes are just big
Caption: fancy ways of storing any kind of data
Caption: that you want and data ponds and data
Caption: puddles are scaled down less
Caption: collaborative versions of data lakes
Caption: are there any questions
Caption: sure sorry i'm putting on the spot there
Caption: okay oh um
Caption: is the unstructured data a key part of
Caption: it being a data lake absolutely yeah um
Caption: it's not just the size and scale
Caption: available and structured structured data
Caption: so the issue with the data warehouse the
Caption: preceded lakes was that a database needs
Caption: structure in order to ingest data so if
Caption: you want to accept data sources from
Caption: literally anywhere and not be picky you
Caption: need to accept unstructured data because
Caption: a lot of sources will give us
Caption: unstructured data
Caption: i was just gonna ask uh have you heard
Caption: of the so-called lake house and you have
Caption: an
Caption: opinion
Caption: yes um
Caption: so lakehouse is commonly sold through
Caption: databricks as one of their products um
Caption: my understanding of it is it's very good
Caption: for an organization that wants a data
Caption: lake but doesn't have a lot of data
Caption: engineering capability themselves so
Caption: it's if you're laughing and you work for
Caption: databricks or something
Caption: it's a way of tying in machine learning
Caption: and artificial intelligence and data
Caption: governance all into a data lake it's a
Caption: bit of an expansion of a data lake and
Caption: it's a bit of a managed product
Caption: cool
Caption: all the way down the other end i saw you
Caption: walk to the back just so i could ask
Caption: that question
Caption: and what are your thoughts on donna mesh
Caption: new term to me
Caption: yep i'll be honest
Caption: what are your thoughts
Caption: i think it's a way of solving some of
Caption: the
Caption: the problems that are going to come okay
Caption: with
Caption: data lakes and
Caption: um data warehouses
Caption: and rebuilding that monolith of data
Caption: and but i was just wondering i won't go
Caption: into detail
Caption: your
Caption: presentations yeah
Caption: i can understand why
Caption: the data lake is very appealing to
Caption: company and i'm curious about how
Caption: in the wild people actually make use of
Caption: it i mean like in your diagram there's
Caption: there's the ai bolt on and there's a
Caption: dashboard but what do people tend to
Caption: actually do with their data lakes
Caption: a lot of reporting
Caption: generally from what i found companies
Caption: will have
Caption: segregated data silos and part of their
Caption: technical revolution whatever is to move
Caption: to a data lake and start to bring all of
Caption: that data into one place i think that
Caption: has some very real benefits in that
Caption: previously you know opposite or
Caption: different teams would have a lot of
Caption: trouble accessing the data of other
Caption: teams and there's a complete nightmare
Caption: of managing you know 100 different
Caption: database clusters and everyone having
Caption: their own way
Caption: there's very little governance in those
Caption: so what i see
Caption: happening is generally just
Caption: consolidating all of that into one
Caption: platform that everyone can use
Caption: it does generate a lot of work for them
Caption: because suddenly data governance becomes
Caption: a must instead of a could um but largely
Caption: what i see it used for is dashboards and
Caption: reporting makes sense thanks cool
Caption: i think we maybe have time for one more
Caption: quick question
Caption: um what about security so if you have
Caption: everyone accessing this data lake how do
Caption: you keep secure data from people who
Caption: shouldn't see it sure
Caption: um
Caption: personally we work within aws so my
Caption: answer will be a bit constrained there
Caption: but
Caption: as with any other system you have to
Caption: secure access in some way there's good
Caption: ways and bad ways of doing that um when
Caption: it comes to things like databases
Caption: themselves you can generate you know you
Caption: have to generate credentials for people
Caption: to log in and use and however you manage
Caption: that is your thing
Caption: for the unstructured stores or s3
Caption: buckets and things like that we always
Caption: recommend that sso is used to
Caption: authenticate and that way you can
Caption: control that only people in your you
Caption: know active directory domain are able to
Caption: access that data but it is a very good
Caption: question in that every company is going
Caption: to handle that a slightly different way
Caption: awesome thank you so much aiden cool um
Caption: thank you yes
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: it's afternoon tea time and then just
Caption: make sure you're back in the main
Caption: theater i think for the lock note at
Caption: 405.
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: nice
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you